i look good here we go
oh i don't want that wine i get nervous
dude we're live
no it's fine don't take it easy you got
to breathe i know i've tried it i should
have done that the thing is don't try to
be funny okay i should have done
calisthenics before i have a
conversation okay
okay you're with your friends yeah i
know i know you're with your friends i
know so you guys let me introduce
everybody okay okay to my left is brian
the kid cowan
there he is what do we stop calling him
the kid though by the way
no no no no no no no no no no no no
internationally known as the man dragon
oh yeah and i want to thank the fans for
not letting me let go of that
dude let me let me redo the intro it's
brian the kid count ak the rings aka big
gay out ak
man dragon yep so many nicks so many
names
and then over there is chris dalia yeah
you guys might know who he is i don't
have a nickname dude because i'm raw and
what you see is what you get and you
know that chris ross you guys know that
you don't say raw delia oh raw dog wrong
well
i'm raw i'm raw what you see is what you
get you know that anyway
it's embarrassing dude be cool yeah dude
i'm i'm going i'm having on camera
persona i'm fine i'm fine honestly it's
great to be here and i love seeing you
guys here it's great to finally meet
josh and you guys are just doing great
orange county real estate is back
uh and then directly across from me he's
won half the weighing in podcast it is
josh thompson
one of the smartest men in the mma world
that's your reputation i mean thanks man
thank you yeah yeah that's pretty close
straight but is it good
john's pretty i know but like being
first uh like being the smartest guy in
mma is like being the the fast kid in
the special olympics wow wow making fun
of people
what was the guy from south africa that
had one leg right he competed in the
real olympics oh
no he killed he murdered his wife
all right right the murderer
but he's pretty [ __ ]
honestly it's a sad story i don't wish
that on anyone but it's great to be here
and did he really do it i have no idea
oh yeah oh yeah yeah no idea i saw a
documentary or two he admitted he
admitted he did it
but i'm gonna ask you to have a
different voice i'm going to ask you to
have a normal voice and not have it on
camera voice i'm just going to ask you
that it's great to be here okay
i'm just happy
just happy i'm blessed you know what i
mean
the drive out here was beautiful and
that's not true we're having a great
time we're really having a great time
it's all about family
so family and god family and god god
first family first then god first and
the core
what i don't know marines sorry oh
peace corps too much bee
oscar pista riot dude his girl was a
smoke show so he admitted to killing her
because he thought it was an intruder oh
right right right right but they had
like horrible domestic violence before
that yeah did they really it's tragic oh
dude there's a whole documentary i think
oh yeah you got to see i saw two of them
yeah all right i saw two dogs
so i'm too up on you on documentaries
but it doesn't matter but that series
was like four parts two i was good on
but she was smoking oh
oh yeah she was so beautiful
sad it's sad all around you oh god dude
no i know i but i get i get real no
i'm sorry don't say obvious [ __ ] i get
real don't say obviously okay oh b you
know what the first fight is they change
it so remember i was telling you how
trevor whitman because he works with
justin gaiji rose
and kamar oozeman yeah they don't make
it up names making up names they don't
have to work back to back all the fights
names don't they move chandler gate to
the first made it up that's what i heard
that's what i heard so we got our bet
going exciting now we have a thousand
dollars get your [ __ ] face we're
gonna we're gonna do i'm up two thousand
dollars so let's let's
do it but then i win something no no
recently i don't know i won everything
last fight i called everything and i was
we owe me like three hundred grand
including
including you owe me 300 credits don't
say that no including
including hey for the cameras we'll keep
doing this but
juice is running listen to me right now
hey this is running you guys don't you
have a sponsor or something like that
oh chris goddard damn it
learn how to i keep it tight you should
run the show
gentlemen the holidays came early
because manscape the leading men's
hygiene brand has launched a new product
an all-new ultra premium body wash and
two in one shampoo and conditioner dude
if you're still using separate shampoo
and conditioners
what are you from the 60s that's crazy
dude they have two in one now it's time
to give yourself the gift of beautiful
skin in here two of the balls this
holiday season i guarantee your hygiene
routine will never be the same go to
manscape.com cfc for 20 off and free
shipping make sure you're feeling and
smelling prepared for a little action
under the mistletoe
mistletoe
two-in-one shampoo all right don't
forget about the flagship product the
lawnmower 4.0 that's the trimmer you can
you can shave your nuts it's in the dark
i usually leave it out i use it and it's
silent it's got a little it's got a
little uh lighter so i'm gonna take that
manscape 4.0 and shave your head what do
you think about that i don't know i
think i honestly i think i might have
some [ __ ] issues with the receding
hairline i don't think it would look
very good yeah you'll be all right but
it's fine get 20 off and free shipping
by going to manscape.com cfc that's 20
off and free shipping with manscape.com
cfc clean up your candy cane this year
with manscape i get it that's a dick
reference and i got it
i'm good like that yeah i get it good
stuff buddy hey don't touch it i want to
rough you up too i want to go right now
y'all fired up after brea huh fire up
and think about me when i see these
fights how thick does joe rogan look
right now he's got he's got his head is
actually bigger than daniel no dc has
that all right his head is popping
they're the evolution of what a guy
should look like by the way
it starts you know less medium
this is like in the video game when you
you can just like hit keep hitting plus
plus plus plus plus and then you get
here at the end look at me how thick his
arms are this is this is also brought to
you by the podcast congratulations you
know the thing about congratulations
that's right it's a great it's a great
are you tired of other podcasts ah come
on man normal [ __ ] you got my pop on
over to congratulations so yeah this is
nothing
what can i find on the bottom chris i
think we're gonna change this
you're welcome yeah no it's not you're
welcome guys and that's offensive dude
it's congratulations
are you tired are you tired of podcasts
or ho-hum you know what come on over to
congratulations
we do the hard-hitting issues man ho-hum
yeah [ __ ] npr
oh wow what do you want to listen to
another [ __ ] five-part thing about
how the air con how air conditioning was
in the 1950s [ __ ] all that we talk about
hard-hitting issues what because you're
raw yeah
oh dude hey how about dc he's been
getting [ __ ] for being biased towards
certain fighters yeah you know but
that's going to come no matter what he
is he is biased he's like no different
than me i'm biased towards the guys i'm
bi and listen i'm not commenting like
you or dc but i'm biased you're the most
you're the most guys like if he's your
friend or whatever oh yeah but i say
that listen
i said my picks are this guy and this
guy i'm biased they're my friends
there's no way he was going against
corey sandhagen yeah but that's good
that's a homie that's a homie yeah but
for dc it's like the [ __ ] they're
getting like well he has uh inside intel
like he knows those guys yeah yeah i
look i think i think
i don't say he was biased towards me but
definitely you know no but i think i
think big john brought up a good point
is that it really comes down to tonight
if chandler and gaichi is not as the
fight that they thought it was going to
be it's not if it doesn't end up in a
finish if it's not an action-packed i
can see islam signing up in that title
shot
one of those guys gets a [ __ ] flash
knockout like a highlight real knockout
submission
or knockouts
yeah i don't even know if chandler takes
him down and submits him in like first
second round
with the good guild team he's got nasty
guilty
i i think it's the best fight on the
card like i think it's i think it's the
most intense
yeah i think it's the most high five
i mean brian bet on it brian has gaichi
and i love gaijin this is the most he's
my boys look at the kids look at the guy
in the back if you were to say that
you could say it was two two going in
the fifth agreed
and i think kobe fought very like
emotional yeah like it wasn't a good
performance let me ask you this about
kobe because i think i'm going to go
with covington it's colby
yeah i don't say kobe
[ __ ] oh way to bring it up dude that
was sad he died it was right up there he
died in a helicopter and you brought it
up and that's [ __ ] up
damn it no colby colby i think
i got him in this fight only on that
never bet against respond he's amazing
well you just did but yeah never but
okay you did it that's my take here's my
take odd i think you're gonna see a lot
of wrestling from cold i think i agree i
think he's gonna wrestle the [ __ ] out of
him don't stand him back
[Music]
i think he's going to wrestle with them
and i think they both have amazing
cardio but um has more muscle to feed
and i think you just got to look at that
for me i'd be like i'm going to kick him
in the legs and i'm going to [ __ ]
blast double them and do whatever i can
you got to look at what in the first
fight get over here colby was able to
rock us
what he's saying colby
colby was able to rock him in the first
night he was able to rock goosebump a
couple times in the first year and that
was a shitty version of kobe yeah and
that's it
why is that he's fighting like
emotions like no head movement now he
has head movement like if the same kobe
that fought woodley brings the same like
tenacity and like iq into the octagon
it's gonna be a better fight well he
went from top team chris your turn no
but the thing is like a little hole in
the wall gym that's just all about him
now why would he better off for him
really why yeah i feel like top team
because the focus oh look at halle berry
she is she fighting what
oh she's with with super powers yeah
i've seen her movies what is she doing
there she looks dude how much prettier
she's getting everybody on that stage
female fight movie dude she's my ass
yeah it's so hot oh my gosh do you think
about the way you've aged the way she's
i know dude i gotta get some [ __ ]
skin tightening what do you do have your
skin loose
dude i don't have my skin i don't know
what's going on just no dude i'm getting
older and i'm maturing i'm finally
setting settling into my body your eyes
are going to disappear into your head
hey dude that's not nice i know what
you're doing all right yeah but you're
saying it it's live and we can't cut it
out and it's [ __ ] all right my eyes
are gonna sink into my head we're live
oh come on dude you've done i heard this
movie's really bad eternals yes well
yeah
i'm just saying that the reviews are
it's that movie yep so it's
it turns you watch that movie stillwater
they made that movie nine times they
made that movie nine times they made it
with uh mark wahlberg they made it with
[ __ ] matt damon and they made it with
justin timberlake it's the same [ __ ]
poster wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait-wait which one
chin hit it what
still water where are you right here
where he goes against this kid no i know
it might be about something a little
different but the poster is exactly the
same it's a kid
her college
oh that's like the amanda knox
yeah oh yeah right it's called homer's
[ __ ] dude look at all the different
ones dude yeah hell yeah he's a tower
justin timberlake
timberlake jt what are you saying he's a
great actor oh he's good he's he's been
good in the business oh hold on
you didn't like him in palmer alpha dog
hold on i didn't see
those movies
you might want to clean that mic why
because i said i spit it oh dude i bring
this i bring this wait why why why
didn't you see those movies chris oh
because they're those movies
why would i watch those why you saw
those
i celebrate when you watch them come on
chris no no it's okay did you have a
movie going experience listen to me
it's dramatic dude no it's dramatic
right right no it's good good you didn't
like um
[ __ ] see it all right all right dude
i love you dude okay what movie but i
didn't see what movie did you see this
year that you thought was excellent yeah
this past year yeah that is yeah
all the time chinchilla chin yeah pull
it up all right
yeah thanks hit it
there we go look at him look at he's
crying that's good he's crying that's
good
you're right there josh i remember what
he did yeah hashtag free britney she's
freed yeah she got free yeah so highly
uh she got her money right she's [ __ ]
free so excited so you can catch me
something like that let them off that
are off yeah i don't know it can't end
well you got gates here chandler
that's a you flip a coin i think this
fight's a flip if you had to bet if
chandler came in i think with the right
game plan engages and gets him to start
brawling and then double blast double
eggs him gets him to grapple and submits
them he seems him submit him in the
first second round if chandler wrestles
he wins if chad doesn't wrestle he loses
really
preach
i miss
the next one i feel the same way about
colby if colby wrestles he has a really
good chance of winning yes you can do
that i'm not saying he's gonna win i'm
saying he's got a good chance of winning
and and and bang bang on his legs if you
were to oh i know the fight you know me
[ __ ] money on canelo caleb plant even
though i hate betting against caleb
because i love him but you would owe me
money i think you're going to be very
surprised i got a couple things to say
about this fight one kill
is in his prime two he's bigger
he's not he's the best number one guy in
the world he's the bigger man three
he is got all he's got great footwork
great jab and
canelo
you sound like steven a smith right now
in the ufc i know but you see
before this they go
did you see him on there it was great
you know because he's the biggest draw
so they come on there what do you think
tonight masquerading as i love it here
man there's been some great fights here
you know
it's just good to be here in the yeah
yeah so what's your favorite like ufc
fight to masquerade
you know muhammad ali fought here and
then you know last time i was here you
know the first fight i've ever seen in
the ufc mcgregor verse eddie alvarez is
like oh dude you just started watching
yourself yeah and i like pancakes 17. i
think caleb plant is
i don't know i think he's amazing i
think he's amazing
i'm gonna win
dude i have a i'm i'm feeling jumpy dude
i like where you're at right now yeah
you want to go 5k on canelo caleb i mean
you're you're getting now hold on
it's very hard for me to bet against
canelo you already did so can you can
you at least get let's bet on something
else got to soften the world you want to
do the covington us
see that's tough see you see what i'm
saying but we you we already have two
grand on caleb plant well we got we got
a gram we can make it years
i'll go two grand okay deal i'll go two
grand let me get my money back no
chandler's walking right now though
do you want to bet on this one you're
betting on this one no you're not
betting on this one
i'll take chandler okay
a grand okay
no no no
minus 250 300 or plus 300. so i'm taking
the dog here because yeah
which i'm very surprised by i i'm
actually very to me it's an even
fight i don't know what these [ __ ]
people who pick the odds are doing well
so he's plus 175 pretty good honorable i
don't think he's better wrestling right
chancellor better yeah but here's the
only thing not an mma wrestler
okay cheryl's definitely the better
wrestler better
savage and chandler's got one of the
best army guillotines and guillotines
when he attacks the next he's [ __ ]
nasty he's a high level black belt yeah
yeah he's he's not a black girl though
is he not i thought he was a black belt
i don't think he is i think i think he's
a black belt is he pretty sure
he's got
i [ __ ] hate chandler but i'm never
gonna say chandler i like jessie
you don't like chandler you know i can't
they have this weird beat why
oh you don't like this guy do you
remember him you remember what i said if
you remember the thing i said last time
i said i was here you guys asked me like
he said he's fake
fake but did you guys watch the 24 7 on
him people are blowing up blowing me up
on instagram social twitter they're like
god everything josh said is [ __ ] true
he talks about how he he's he's like oh
well you know i knew i was gonna be a
fighter when i came out of my mom's womb
i was fighting to get out of her [ __ ]
her vagina
and all this i'm like i didn't see it 24
7 but people were just hitting me up
with tweets and texts and stuff talking
about just it's all scripted it's
scripture he's a nice guy though you're
both
no but i think part of that josh might
be the pressure of being a showman and
having a statement he's always been that
way but you know he's chris he couldn't
but he's a christian's workshop so i
think he's like i think he's a good
fighter
but there's a separation
when you're when you work at the desk
right i just like both of you guys you
got to say something i guess you know
something nice about them but i think i
think we are chandler here yeah i think
you guys can be professional about it
yeah
you guys just have problems all the time
yeah what what is the not all the time
everyone's sensing he's fake he's fake
he thinks
i don't think he's fake i know he's you
both have fantastic jawlines they're
well they're both handsome as [ __ ]
dude dude this is exciting this guy's
got his name on his back yes
well like it's a jersey cool dude like
he's wearing a jersey you have one on
your own no i'm just saying i got one
you should put a number nine under
internet i want to give you a shove
around wow dude hey brian hey you know i
broke rapport's rib huh you did sure did
how how
he kept talking [ __ ] to me and then
wanted me to wrestle my rap i don't want
to do this yeah and then i did it he
grabbed armor in the in the hallway i
squeeze him as hard as i can here he
asked me to do it
squeeze him nice like an evil villain
and you squeezed him and he hurt yeah
and now he got to go to the doctor i did
not ask for this oh wow did you really
break his rib that's what he said to me
look at the [ __ ] way you're smiling
dude here's the thing though i'm having
a good time somebody how does someone
that trains as much as he does he's
going to so you got cardio for days
not only
i'm not one to talk that great
i don't know how you [ __ ] up in the
hallway josh not everybody kind of just
ain't back like you
but a lot of the guys aren't shredded
like the [ __ ] the diaz guy was yeah
but he was like
i know oh
yeah she was shredded with the first
robbie the fight he was ripped like
where the [ __ ] is that diaz go now
chandler's pretty jacked no he's he's
got a face
i mean this is insane he's blessed well
that's why it says blessed he's yeah
he's kind of bad he's a [ __ ]
dog
how about the fact that both of these
guys and i know some of them are your
friends but both of them have terrible
he starts off late
kicks chandler channel doesn't take like
kicks very well at all
coming up with bruce to me so fire
that's i i can't wait for that i'm gonna
go gate november
shooting it really yeah can you do it
oh i think so this is the idea
wow those tattoos huh
eyes underneath you know what advantage
you have chris is you got tattoos later
in life yeah i know yeah you got to get
them later so you know what you want
or not and you have money so you who did
them like dr wu yeah your tattoos are
turkeys no they're not yeah there are
they're not dude i know for a fact
you don't have any right you don't have
any josh
no no you don't put a barber sticker on
a bentley no they're not i know for a
fact i know for a fact my tattoos are
awesome
okay
you can joke about whatever you want
right right
big bet alert one better is back in my
channel with 6k if it hits you hit win
16-5 yeah oh
is the favorite here yes wow that's him
that's gay i know that because he's at
the back of his back
has more power more explosive he does he
does it's one shot
but challenge chin's not as good as his
you should get those i'm gonna get two
eyes right above your eyes
it would look so good and then two pairs
of sunglasses oh good call izzy he just
do the backflip off the cage
[Laughter]
oh this guy dude he's great he's he's
yeah
it's basically like they got the ufc got
mad because big john became such a big
name big john so what they did was they
they said look we don't want the
referees to be able to remember yamasaki
used to do this yeah the hard thing got
fired you can't do that [ __ ] no more why
like they they don't want that they
don't want you to become like a bigger
than the fighters yeah they don't want
to be individuals ooh there goes like
it's so weird you would you channel
would have to train for them leg kicks
you know yeah but he's got those little
chicken legs [ __ ]
you touch him in the calf
two three times oh taylor's throwing
chandler is so explosive in and out
camera's gonna win this fight he's got
russell gates got to kick more he just
needs to get him again
i bet he takes him down off the leg kick
he's gotta take josh he's got a kick i
mean she gets them down off the leg kick
kick oh
[ __ ] come on justin gets there too
justin there it is he's heavy on that
front he doesn't like to be kicked at
all but you got to figure he knows it's
going in he's doing well with it but he
just
yeah yeah look at that he's just
in and out challenge smart he'll wrestle
hey chris don't play doesn't look like
he's like
he's gonna throw okay he's gonna catch
he's gonna throw a big right and then
get him down okay he's falling in love
with his power lately chandler has okay
she's got that
oh
see i think he's going to do this and
tyson in the war and then get him down
nope there it is
go kick himself
get off the cage chandler get off the
cage dude oh damn oh they are the same
[ __ ] it slugging this this trailer this
is game though i agree this is a
terrible bet if chandler's going to
fight like this yes he's terrible
chancellor's down he's going to be
falling into it falling oh he just hurt
himself throwing a kick the thing too is
gaechi he looks tired he just powers
through it yeah he's just [ __ ] oh
oh
jesus oh i don't like this for a
cheerleader take him down
[ __ ] dude
she's being very chris if i lose pay
brian for me yeah but i don't know how
much you have money uh
oh that one hurt him that jab hurt him
oh the seat this one challenge starts to
slow down when the adrenaline is gone he
has a lot of muscles down so much a lot
of muscle engage he's like a tidal wave
dude yeah
okay gacha will just keep walking oh
[ __ ] see you guys gonna take all of
those all day long because gage is a
[ __ ] savage
jesus christ i just don't like to
hopefully change the story look at
chandler's foot look at how red and
broken yes oh [ __ ] he probably hit his
one or two kicks there it is he kicked
the foot it hurts him more than him god
these boys are throwing looks like
chandler's foot's bleeding too is it his
right foot yeah yeah yeah might have
broke his foot look at that how he's
slipping shots
look at him slip in these shots gage is
hard to [ __ ] connect on might just
broke that one little bone
oh
oh that rocked him a little bit that
rock chandler a little bit yeah he's
coming in why is he not wrestling
dude oh [ __ ] see chandler has more power
chandler has power oh look he's
hitchhiking oh [ __ ] but gage is going to
be there man
oh
my god he's cool's got his hands down
[Applause]
there it is he's got to wrestle he's not
getting him
is he down up how is he it must be his
second set of eyes
chandler's cut bad over the eye i don't
know about that
he's got a massive cut over that eye
he's got some eyes on his spin
man that's a terrible
okay
this is this is this is gaechi's fight
like this is how you watch the fight
so why wouldn't why is that
going to get knocked out about to get
knocked out i agree and i'm not and i'm
not saying no i agree with you like
anyone can knock each other out in this
fight but
no
why wouldn't the other guy try to take
there it is right there a little
uppercut he's gonna hit him
why not blast double why not [ __ ] but
that's what i asked why wouldn't he how
can you know why how can you be such a
good wrestler
such good ground power such vicious
ground a pound
and [ __ ] not wrestle chandler had him
wobble dude
oh man jesus i mean he's not doing it to
prove a point right uh sometimes really
for sure
oh that uppercut got hurt
that uppercut's there for him chandler's
already slowed down he's already blown
his wad gage is going to just keep doing
the same pace that he does dude
remember gateshead trains at altitude
yep so as this fight goes on he's gonna
continue to be there yep oh and this is
all which he does [ __ ] [ __ ] amen i'll
tell you what though chandler's an
absolute god
saying you got to do a [ __ ] hole you
got to do it earlier
oh no he's losing this round he's not
losing it now but he's
he's going to taylor won this round
yellow on the round but i mean if gaijin
was able to drop him he ends up doing it
he'll steal it got that uppercut dude
that uppercut that'll get scared [ __ ]
dude dude what a [ __ ] fight oh
another man kick the legs
kick the legs more chandler's exhausted
come on gaichi let's [ __ ] go
oh that's a [ __ ] around son
by the time he shot he was exhausted you
know yeah yeah gaijin's hips are too
good to shoot half-assed like that i
mean it looked pretty easy when cabi
took him down different different animal
different animal
taylor's
wrestling but he's got good wrestling
he's got to do it when he's fresh i
always forget with that with you with
mma you keep your hands down i'm always
like keep your hands up but you get
taken down sometimes no you you just got
to learn that
brian it's
i know it's not necessarily true but you
i feel like you're being a little
condescending so i'm saying you might
want to
you might
you're being concerned i'm sorry i just
okay you threw me for a living oh no
brian you're not supposed to do that
i've doubled up on it hold three it's
making me mad
oh that that doesn't really hit the
shoulder yeah
right there that's where he commanded
jesus christ he had him going but see
that like i said he had him on sixth
street you can you because you can't say
queer street anymore right no that's
right upon right ryan i don't know about
that i think it's okay
because where's queer street queer
street is where you're not i feel queer
i feel like i'm i'm not there
i think it's one straight over from six
yeah i don't think it's a gay i said six
straight shout out to i say texas queer
street
is more likely to become a thing he's on
sixth straight like queer queer is the
ideological you can't
oh you can't be somewhat difficult you
can't label me most kong
right you can't label me something no
you can still say queer because it's not
referring to like queer person i could
say queer street
oh there we go oh oh jesus christ
what's this now what is that about
saying he is not um keep getting keep
kicking that leg
chris have you ever been to a ufc fight
live no you know rogan never gave
tickets or nothing i never went cam
haynes is there tonight
chris you do you campaigns
he's like
i know who he is i didn't know you call
him cam hayes dude have you ever because
it was getting on me dude i saw him once
uh
have you ever been in the woods dude i'm
asking don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
asking a question
do you think you'd survive me yeah yeah
dude no no no no dude no you wouldn't
ikea i would have to carry you on my
back justin just waiting for the
breakdown
of the leg man i know he's got to keep
going on the leg oh
god i'm telling you that uppercut keep
his back off the fence
the best when he's the bully yes you
have to get off the [ __ ] cage dude
i don't know how you make this
a good podcast one of these fights are
stressful i know they are oh my god the
uppercut's there for gages
oh my god
i called
here this is smart come on katy
should just break the grip and stand
back what a miserable place to be well
the most miserable
here yeah they're both you're well
you're crying to recover you're in the
second round both of them are exhausted
they're both hating life right and
you're holding on
god gate she's a mother what if gaijin
submitted him
he's never been submitted
okay
never been submitted that's right
oh wow
yeah nasty he
remember that old uh uh world star video
somebody called ambulance amber alert
remember that
you remember that oh he leaking he's
smiling
wow i think it's more of a grimace jim
this is like if i when i look at things
like that this is someone who is just
he's he's just happy that he's
in the ufc fight chandler yeah he has
that like he almost beat charles
oliveira i
know wait a minute they just got back up
this is entertaining is 35 years old
though it's like how much longer you're
going to do this try to get some wins
man i mean he's trying dude but they
gave him charles oliveira and justin
gaichi his first fight was josh you're
so harsh on him i can't take it no no
you're a little bit of a hater but i get
such a hater right but that's why i love
josh at least he's not fake
i know he's being a hater for nothing
you want josh
in your corner you got to respect a nice
right you got a receipt
oh he's got look i've never said he
wasn't a good fighter
he's such a warrior he's a [ __ ] dog
oh he's a warrior you go back and watch
his old fights with [ __ ] uh he's just
got to say he's got to shoot he's going
to set up his shots
he's raw dog oh that uppercut is all
right how do you keep from getting up
he's god damn it he's chris rodelias
keep your hands oh oh my god
look at it and engaging smiles at you
talking to each other just a couple of
dudes talking about god what a [ __ ]
fight to kick this big you know what he
has to quit shooting
right now i wanted to take him out and i
don't want him he looks like he's never
wrestled before he's like i agree oh
he's long lazy she's just eating that up
but you got to keep your hand it's it's
hard like he probably came in around 185
they were talking about what he's
i was telling my boy todd filming he's
like gate she's bigger i'm like i
promise you dude no you're the fight
chandler's huge gage he's taller yes he
comes in probably about 170.78
chandler is a monster there was a video
that he had i can't remember who it was
for i think it was when he fought uh
premise the first time he was so jack he
sent a picture of himself on the scale
and he was 191
i want chandler to win this fight
because i don't care about losing the
money he's winning a warrior
gage is winning this fight oh yeah
why aren't you giving any glove to get
you you're such a hater i love gates you
said
no that was a punch
what do you can't stop a fight if you
got punched in the eye go back and see
if the punch is over chandler wins
wait what yeah will they do that yes
because you cannot call
in the timeout watch
watch it's a punch
boom
it's done whatever he pushes off right
here oh no look they're back there oh
it's a poke that's a poke poke oh so
it's okay so yeah okay okay okay damn
it's okay it's a poke
but i'm saying the the shot i saw was
the first round
if he turns and stops the fight because
it was a punch it was legal
yeah oh so that's a forfeit technically
well that was like a bellator fight with
minikoff last week his finger was this
way and he couldn't put it back in it
was at the end of the round so he like
looked at the ref for help yeah
oh he's also the end around nice dude
hey chris just so you know josh does a
podcast called weighing in with big john
and big john's like the like gold
standard for refs
he's done he's involved in all of like
the the stuff that goes on now for the
weight cut like if you have questions
about anything not that you would but
i'm just saying like if people do you
call him but see what you guys just saw
i just learned this [ __ ] last week
and i've been a fighter for 20 years see
like these things yeah because we had uh
in bellator two weeks ago in russia one
of the heavyweights his fear got
dislocated and then his his opponent was
like one head his finger was like
pointing this way yeah and the ref's
like we'll put it back in and then even
his opponent was like go ahead put it
back in he couldn't get it back in so he
looked to the ref like okay i need help
then the rest is like done
the fight's over i can't call timeout
hey josh would you have gave that seg
around ten eight wow no no oh you're ten
nine really ten nine so it's even though
yeah
because chandler won the first round
yeah i had engagement winning dominantly
but it's not quite that's why i like the
half point system it should have been
like a ten seven and a half yeah they
don't do that though yeah they don't do
it yeah wow
see i see how i give that round almost
like
i would say it could be closer to it i
mean sorry it'd be like it'd be a ten
it'd be a ten a yeah ten and a half we
weren't even watching the fight last
time i know we were just fine it wasn't
but it wasn't this good but though
your defense they were different cars
this is a this is a
big boy yeah like you're into it yeah
yeah yeah yeah this realistic could main
event any other fight card this could
have been a pay-per-view this car this
fight right here could have made it
about no i i i've seen this guy's fight
before it's incredible chris you have
any questions for me uh jesus yeah okay
sure how much was that shirt
i remember vince
i used to i used to yeah dude when it
was popular i'm handsome as [ __ ] in this
shirt i i've had a lot of women tell me
that okay well well
and i am handsome b what did you you had
a bunch of boxes what did you walk in
with wine and what else i'll tell you
just [ __ ] too much wine too many
glasses dude
cheese or something no they have cheese
no he rocks my broccoli
who drinks wine besides brian
great body shots wow great body shots we
should oh oh my god this is a
[ __ ] is are people going nuts
online and oh my god
again this is long-lasting damage in a
couple months how many times he's
getting hit in the [ __ ] head yes it
is it's long-lasting damage right yeah
yeah yeah look at chandler's leg that
one that one hurt him a little bit he
switched his stance right he broke the
first rule of fight club josh
[Applause]
[ __ ] that was crazy what a takedown
highlight does that count as a takedown
no no no no no what even [ __ ]
happened i wasn't encountered i felt bad
i broke the rule and then it's basically
it's like a change in position no
different than like if i had you pressed
against the fence
and put me against the fence
man
this is why i do a show big john he
[ __ ] walks me through all this
for sure
she's distracting wow she is distracting
she's fighting next i don't know man
she's gonna float down into the ring oh
i know this fight is a [ __ ] i wish it
was five minutes five rounds oh my god
is that how [ __ ] tough is chandler
though it's only five thank god i mean
this is like the ortega one kinda yeah
look at him look at him right i know how
gangsters chandler dude dude i think
this round decides to fight it does
close it looks good
the [ __ ]
[Applause]
this is this is insanity he's just
walking with his handstand right
remember when we got in a fight like
this in the back of the lap factory yup
yup and then it was a little just like
you can't wait three rounds it was three
rounds and you were like a ghost i was
like i know you couldn't hit me i was so
crazy i know and i had my venom shorts
because you cheated and used you used
kung fu i know
you're losing this fight with this
behavior why did he walk forward with no
[ __ ] hand i think he's just he's just
like
we're going nice it looks like his
hand's messed up this is yeah he did
start pointing his hand but i don't know
what that means this is crazy broken
hand it could be i i this is this is
hospital stuff for he's still oh well
you got to love this fight see this you
got to fight you got to fight the grin
to the the crowd the
yeah in the crowd
i like it but you gotta you gotta be
going got it this fight's too close for
you to be doing it i see i see yeah it
did this right like literally like these
last 30 seconds to decide yeah you got
to win you got to go down you got to win
this round you guys give it to chad
chandler i thought chandler's dancing
dancing close it's closed he's dancing a
little close but i would give it to gate
slightly unless something happens here i
don't know i think something's wrong
with chandler broke his hand yeah i
think i give it to gaijin i think i got
you probably
how can you tell
because he's not throwing him yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah ah [ __ ]
he
that's a [ __ ] fight dude jesus
incredible that was a [ __ ]
fight they kiss
yeah
i don't know how the [ __ ] you deal with
that kind of punishment have you ever
been josh you ever been in a bang fest
like that unfortunately yeah you have
with against two the second gilbert
fight was like that oh my god it was
five rounds though we had five rounds
[ __ ] five yeah melendez man so him
and i had three we had three fights five
rounds each so tough classic yeah by the
way and what's the recovery time after
that well the second fight
yeah
nine years yeah you know there's not
recovery that's nine years off your life
that's not there's no recovery
the second fight i had to sleep with the
necro pillow for like three four days
sitting up i couldn't put my head down
like a car accident
cuts and big bumps and lumps and
everywhere all in my head like
gilbert
was one of the toughest [ __ ] he was
talking about
you bring him up hit it chin hit it
uh
that was a ten eight round be a draw
so you give that this last round of
chances you can say chandler won the
last so i'm saying you could say channel
won the last round
i would slightly give the edge to the
game i'm giving it to geichi either way
whoever loses i don't think like nobody
is going to get robbed
what we're going to see is we're going
to see a rematch yeah and but they're
going to give it to uh i'll watch this
fight every saturday
and just sit here with you guys
beautifully boom
see how he landed
i didn't see that the first time
they might give that uh take down they
might listen judges are [ __ ] morons
so that's what you said
that's my thing this is very true yeah
but how is that that's a [ __ ] job
they're going to give it to you didn't
take as much damage man
right there that's right yeah because
you got to realize chandler has like
the scar tissue on his face so he's
going to cut easier yeah but he just
took a lot of he took a lot of it man i
i just saw him getting man chandler gave
a lot of it too though yeah challenge
the gates didn't have a mark on him
would you guys be good with the draw
yeah i love to have it i love draws i
love you on the live we've seen a five
round fight main event now yes i'd love
to see a drone and it's real money and
the thing is like the reason why i like
to see a draw is because
these guys even though i can't [ __ ]
stand this guy okay but i'm saying right
now i've said it a bunch of times he's a
[ __ ] great fighter he's great my boy
that's my boy you got to keep it real
with the two i got to keep it real both
of them are [ __ ] amazing tip of the
spirit like definitely top three in the
video exactly and no one loses or not
i don't think anyone loses
what was the scoring do we know you i
don't know but someone who does it was
unanimous
for chandler but after that fight
everybody wants to see him fight again
it's tough man two losses you lost to
the champion he lost the gates you
should be fighting next you know yeah i
mean
it's tough so here's the stuff
so where's your take on the islam thing
how do you look last week please gonna
win the belt that's what there's no guys
so my point is is why even why even
bother going to gate she didn't have him
fight next have them fight somebody else
have them fight there is no they have to
have them
go right at the time see i disagree
because
charles and dust are fighting december
10th
yes
um yeah
so what i mean it depends so islam and
geichi just fought i'd have islam and
gaijin fight for the number one
contender spot he walks through geichi
but you but he needs to prove it because
you can't just you can't be you can't
beat dan hooker on short notice then get
a towel shot even though we know how
good he is you can't do that but with
short notice it's still four weeks it
doesn't matter
he's already here he just fought two for
that who else has got a towel shot so he
really had six weeks but still you beat
dan hooker who's great but you're not
you're not being a gate you're a
chandler or a dozen boys
i mean honestly honestly i thought i
think i think chandler was the harder
fight for for uh charles for no for
islam
yeah yeah i think i think chandler was
the harder fight for islam geichi will
be taken down when he's saying down same
thing that happened with could be yeah
it's gonna be very close what i try to
tell people is this look i i and i'm
training with both of them for a long
time
khabib is dominant wrestling he's the
most dominant champion has ever existed
in the sport
ever the most dominant champion not i'm
not saying the longest standing like
with chris john jones and those guys
right
now but he's yeah pay attention that's
right follow us
you got to speak the language yeah yeah
okay okay walks right through and walks
right through yeah
islam has the submissions as long as the
guy that has the better submissions is
the only guy that has the better islam
better than transitions
he will he will attack the technique
just does he show up
you know as a main event yeah yeah yeah
i think a little bit of the nerves got
to him that time but i mean you look at
where he was his last fight right he
[ __ ] is that that was impressive i'm
not arguing he's gonna be a champ it's
just weird i think to go from hooker
yeah to a straight title shot against
these dogs yeah but i'm gonna go through
a chandler and get you to get there yeah
but you know went through poker to get
to donald's shot
different though he's former world
champion from bellator i guess i didn't
knock hooker out in what 30 seconds
that two years a minute twenties still
so so good yeah
did he come up in khabib's camp your
best friend from there they've been
friendly since killing they said yeah
kindergarten yeah so he's just uh
kindergarten khabib 2.0
it's just he's not as good as the
grappling hey khabib
so he is to me so he is the better [ __ ]
style foot sweeps hip toss he's a strike
guy he's got better striking islam he's
the better foot sweeps and hips and hip
toss those kind of guys and better
striking yeah he's got better
submissions than khabib
khabib is the better double leg single
leg double leg lift chain wrestle key to
the ground mentality [ __ ] smash okay
so let me ask you this is it
are they such so hard to deal with
because they're kind of speaking a
different language is it the great they
are speaking in different languages
but their wrestling is different than
folk wrestling right their wrestling is
different than the freestyle americans
different style it's that sambal it's a
mixture between [ __ ] judo and put on
the world
yeah not just greco but it's uh on the
world stage they'll not win like winning
oh wow what do you mean are they what
are you doing in the olympics what are
you [ __ ] talking about
hit it
yeah russian wrestling i started
corruption wrestlers that won the
olympics are placing everything in
first second or third yeah they're all
from china hit it quicker yeah
it's not alive i thought a lot of just
the b just beat kyle snyder for the what
about the third time john burns was in
the olympics this year
but i'm just saying he never lost a dog
he did he did no yeah that's how he lost
that's why he's not talking about bronze
he won gold then he took bronze yeah he
lost to the russian kid i believe uh
top wrestlers in the world yeah go to
that chin
no monsters
okay well he's not from dagestan no no
well that's not b yeah what's racism
it could be anyone could be from
anywhere oh look no it brought up a
bunch of names jim if you go back for
some reason it's not what those guys are
offering
well that guy's from russia said russia
they are so wanna click
yeah correct
i'm not arguing with you uh josh i'm
just saying i don't know i figured yeah
and cal snyder no don't get me wrong so
kyle snyder lost to uh start alive start
alive is [ __ ] the best right now in
the world hands down he just went up
[ __ ]
kyle snyder the man
then uh literally all restaurants
bruce bomb
is such a freak i used to i watched his
fight he's just so unbelievable bruce
baumgartner looks tough
with a cigar just [ __ ] grabbing this
guy's hair dude who is helen mark i'll
[ __ ] him up
oh uh uh
marlo
she's american no she's american
no you're making you're making okay
points but they're just a little no i'm
saying if you watch that it looks like a
bunch of uh russians and
the school teacher just yeah
handling pick you up and throw you yeah
yeah smith who so uh go who won the most
gold medals in wrestling uh last year
not low last year
you'd only be a one-way class
what'd you say you don't be in one
weight class really so you only win one
yeah there's no open division where you
wrestle everyone yeah yeah you just when
you're understanding who won the most
golds
oh it would be uh the russian kid uh the
kid from uh i'm saying like country wise
from siberia no he's from russia scroll
down chin i don't care about that
they're all into the russian system even
the chinese are under that russian
system like
oh you don't know so japan's one the
most it says
that can't be right come on
it's a woman uh
not that
there goes which country has the most
olympic gold medals
u.s u.s leads
[ __ ] you first you know for 2021 or for
just for 2021 or forever it says 2020.
yeah for 2021.
that was just all the time
america no way we didn't sound like a
russian spy no we didn't get a good we
didn't get good wrestling until later on
recently
so john smith dave schultz those guys
started coming into the scene we didn't
get it yeah we didn't have really good
wrestling until then yeah they were they
were dominating the scene this guy this
guy's such a freak this suit alive he's
such a freak he's started he's now he
does kyle steiner go to ohio state
where's he go he used to go to ohio
state yeah yeah he's done now i believe
that's america yeah but then the kid
black dude who's uh the ufc
yep you have steve you won gold yeah he
won gold uh yeah he's still one he's at
minnesota university of minnesota he's
going back he's got one more year with
wwe yeah as the ambassador yeah
such a good boxer ian gary that guy in
the prelims
english guy came up he's like that he's
6-3 and 170
and huge for the weight class but his
boxing is he grew up he was going to
represent uh yeah
in the in the olympics in boxing mm-hmm
and now he's in mma
james you're talking pretty limbs dog he
wanted against that guy that he's the
guy how did this fight
end up getting ahead of
because of the chandler thing yeah yeah
yeah wait what was the problem i was
trying to figure out because
they was co-main event yeah the featured
fighter card so he can't warm them up
yeah so to make it easier on yeah they
broke it up
that's good yeah trevor whitman's doing
something wrong and something well
yes i didn't have a 30 27 i had a 29 28
oh 100 i'm 32 yeah come on the first
round yeah youtube channel
i 29 uh yeah but he didn't get the first
one the other guy did right
well one guy just gave him three judges
there's always a [ __ ] he's like thirty
twenty second round and third round two
uh gauge here i had first round for
chandler yes
you're still like over at aka right well
i mean like i almost i don't train
anymore i don't share with the fighters
anymore all right [ __ ] no i'm trying to
hit no more come on bruh come on
nobody wants to get hit like i thought
maybe do you go back again you go back
to like
but i'll never like spar no i walk past
the cage now i see i hear these guys
getting hit i'm just disgusted
good luck with that oh yeah this kid's a
stud burgos
[ __ ]
he's just nasty
i heard shaubazi and uh
diddy
he's from new york needs to work on his
wrestling yeah he's everything else
about him was good tonight did he he was
getting guillotined and [ __ ] he lost
he lost yeah i figured he would yeah i'm
trying to remember who he fight
uh stud
rusher dagestani who only strikes
which are my f yeah which is fantastic
the name isn't possible though no no his
last name is easy
he's a beast he's a beast
oh that dude uh pierre who beat uh star
bender looked [ __ ] great flying knee
kale flying yeah i saw i saw that when i
walked in i was driving he's giving me a
problem they're gonna make him walk
through fire to get the izzy no they're
not they're gonna make
yeah is only stand up yes
yep but uh what house is wrestling
not good or wrestling but it doesn't
matter easy to diversity doesn't matter
izzy's not gonna take him down yeah i
think he beats him in mma do you think
he does oh yeah i think i think it will
make a difference yeah it will because
there's you're able to clench get to the
fence elbows there's a lot of skin
izzy's been dominating mma for a hot
second
what'd you think of glover
[ __ ]
so great phenomenal you know people hit
me up because we did the whole gambling
thing on our site and so we did uh we
pushed it i said hey if glover to share
i was telling everyone all of our
listeners i said if glovercars gets
taken down early in the first round i
said [ __ ] i said you guys put in the
live betting between rounds put your
[ __ ] house on him he [ __ ] put the
house on them people are betting on
[ __ ] people like dude i won [ __ ]
eighteen thousand dollars anyone wants a
thousand dollars like
800 bucks
like as far as like experts go if we
want to call ourselves xbox every single
person i know pig glover how's the
desert like chuck liddell that's funny
yeah
though
who fought both of them yeah i had him
on food truck oh well the cory also buys
two because he don't like yeah he
doesn't like he'll like either you know
again but he beat glover though he beat
glover he beat john too you're in the
[ __ ] desert he beat him we lost him
right before this whole thing there was
a little animosity there i could talk
about it man i really believe that like
[ __ ] you i had gloved to take down the
first time
dude
they're talking about you're talking
about i'm not i'm not i'm whispering to
him i'm whispering to him dude sorry
because he's talking [ __ ] but he doesn't
know what the [ __ ] he's talking about
every time he says something you guys
are like no i'm all right no that's not
true
i'm i'm a deep you don't know what the
[ __ ] i know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about no you don't do you for a [ __ ]
day
chris you think if you drink some
whiskey to turn into gremlin i think if
i drink some whiskey i would be really
knowledgeable about what's going on okay
but take that you know what i mean
if you drink whiskey yeah that's like i
probably drive your ferrari home
like yo let's go
i got you buddy yeah it's not a [ __ ]
station
and that's support thank you very much
you know what it's funny as i saw the
video you guys the other day and you're
in your car you did a video the other
day in your car and someone's like oh
man he's like you're kind of like
flashing a little bit at the ferrari in
the back seat you didn't mean to catch
it what can you do i know but caught it
and i was like oh you guys are slick
i was like i should redo it but i don't
like to redo videos i'm wrong what you
see is what you get why did you buy a
[ __ ] fry that doesn't look like a
ferrari it's a why'd you buy one without
a tail it's a [ __ ] hatchback
i like hatchbacks oh it's so annoying
with this [ __ ] but that's the ultimate
daddy [ __ ] [ __ ] daddy daddy's
exactly no look at that [ __ ] i don't
say this
okay that looks like the panorama
and why take your general chain off you
don't need it that is dude
bro you it's general bro
outside here you're talking to me about
that
you look like you're on [ __ ] that old
game guess who no i don't yeah you do
you'd be a character and guess who that
i would flip the [ __ ] down in the
beginning of the game now he's like a
sim card slam sim card i said guess what
[Laughter]
make it easy on your not sim
listen there's two things you'll want if
you wanna call to give you some good
advice yeah you don't want advice on
fashion no yes
sure is [ __ ] not cars oh dude hey
talking to me about cars and fashion
yeah what else you got hey listen no no
no in your red tesla dude only guy who's
getting that [ __ ] red thing oh no i
don't know he's got a red text
information he got already had a red
prius that's what it was
uh what'd you call
oh you're not doing well no no no no no
no no
you got the color that was left over
dude you know three of those i asked
them and they're not and they're not
scary i asked for partially brian what
did i tell you i said dude he pulled up
in that red tesla or that red prius yeah
dude we're going to start a podcast
together and you're going to get out of
this thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah i call him he goes
like this
really
yeah he did i said i bet my bottom
dollar off yeah yeah yeah and then i put
brian on my back
and for years
and look at them now yeah i know now
you've got out of it dude i have a red
tesla fake revisionist history listen
funny because brian was telling stories
today his back was sore from carrying
him that's what he was saying yeah
hey bro yeah yeah i i deliberately said
i want barcelona red i said call it the
red ram
dude you flipped i used to park it
illegally because nobody gave me a
ticket because they were like this guy
has a red prius so you flipped it dude
we said we started making fun of your
red prius and then you're like i gotta
come up with a name to seem like i
[ __ ] own this [ __ ] i draw red ram
also red ram is a stupid [ __ ] name
because there's dodge rams right yeah
bless you knew that was going to happen
i'm good
i'm psychic covered did you get you you
had a little fluid i never had it oh
okay you never had kobe yet i work out
and take care of my
aaron body got it sexual chocolate baby
he works out he works out he's fine
he's easy whatever people are [ __ ]
furious about him
sponsors are pulling him from him no
richie is no i know about the hospitals
like we're not working with you anymore
yes i know i love internationals
also he looks like the guy that would
not get the vaccine i mean you so i
guess so many uh other football players
have been blowing them up and like dear
god thank you for speaking out oh good
yeah
you guys are all doing it man
here's here's the here's the craziest
thing because the girl that books our
venues for
bellator she books the venues for like
other like for the madison square garden
remember rogan went to msg yeah sold out
right
whatever so it sold out vaccines yeah
but
he didn't have to get it
he didn't he got an exception
and then the mayor's like like they're
doing it so you can't get away with that
anymore no no no no because nba can
still go there and players are not
vaccinating from other states where they
don't require it i think kyrie irving
can't play because of accidents you're
right but he plays there yeah he played
he lives in new york plays you're out of
town if you're another you come you're
good but the new yeah
apparently the new mayor who's coming in
he's getting rid of all that so kyrie's
gonna be able to play in everything did
you get a vaccine oh so he's not so he's
not gonna yeah i gotta go oh that's the
rumor i got i got uh
he's the second black mayor to be
elected yeah yeah yeah no the first one
was i got vaccinated the guy who was the
uh executive producer for bellator david
jenkins uh dad was like was the uh first
black mare you got backstage
i got vaccinated would you johnson
johnson ten times i got um ten times i
got uh moderna
and that's it okay about 10 times
chris is the guy that came to his house
during like the height of pandemic here
we [ __ ] go
he made me hang out in his backyard six
feet apart yeah i gave him [ __ ] i
gave him food
but then i was all up on your kid you're
like right it's time to get going i know
no i that was when we didn't know what
the [ __ ] it was
that was like what in in in exactly yeah
last june whenever it was april june
july and i was like i was like i don't
know what the [ __ ] this is i was scared
bro you still are though no i'm not what
are you talking about i was [ __ ] on
new shows burgers i'm using this fight
i'm out i was that [ __ ] uh what's a
complex con today
everyone's coughing on me
they have sneakers there
yeah they do yeah no i got no sneakers i
got some clothes though i don't know
what you're telling me you guys are in
your 40s almost you're in your 40s and
you're almost through your 40s don't
talk about sneakers
are you not 40 years old no wait how
hard this guy how are you
[ __ ] baby i know what a [ __ ] 48 no
yeah well you look young as [ __ ]
he looks for a fight or two i thought
you were 44.
you're 48. i'm 44. oh
no
but even live but i had him going yeah
yeah
though
yeah yeah we're talking about fashion
we're talking about high the highest
fast i'm asking if they were dope dude
you're dog you're being shitty no i'm
i'm really curious
jordan ones but a couple
with
travis scott or
i
also maybe you know don't bring up
travis scott that's okay that's true
yeah that's a bad yeah that's a tough
one today all right were they the ones
with
tupac's hologram wow
i should have said nas
oh
his new album is fire dude oh brian it's
a cringe what dude i just what's one
track on his new album i'm young
man i'm gonna be there like i think you
sound like
you sound like biden trying to get
millennials to get back that's not true
dude i'm young and i talk about just
young references i'm young and i'm
talking about are you on tick tock bro
i i'm blessed are you are you asked to
have a dude
do i answer the question i came up he's
not on there i came up with this
business plan for brian only fans
account with his nuts that's a good idea
because he has real big nuts
and we dress his nuts up
he says that because let me see you're
having a hot day they're not big it's
just like this is super small and it
makes his balls look big no his penis is
super small and it makes his balls look
bigger
yes it is dude and you have three balls
like that
you have three balls and it's [ __ ]
gross with three balls and three nipples
there wow wait brent how the [ __ ] do you
know this by the way oh he sent me a
picture of him bent over i said hotel
room oh you don't have brian's number
because if you have brian's number you
know how his balls look yeah and they're
they're like 100 they're like a molasses
heavy yeah they're the color of the red
ram that's what they're looking forward
to remind me never to give you my
[ __ ] help yeah no no no no i knew you
don't have a chin chin this is the [ __ ]
i'm walking you know what you gotta help
me out i got it brian's not you send
pictures i got it brian's nuts chin hit
him
if you want to send me i'll show the
guys
i don't know
that's what your [ __ ] big ass juicy
nuts are like
and it's a shame
and it's a shame you have eleven titus
of the night i do
guys here's the bottom line qr code guys
listen i'm gonna be i'm gonna be in
naples this weekend hey shut the [ __ ] up
dude there's a picture of brad it's
awesome there you go there's brian here
oh my god
why does he have a [ __ ] in his balls
that's disgusting
that's a problem i think that's fake
well it looks kind of like a butthole
though yeah
it's the thing in the heck
i have this is crazy those are real
pictures on the left though by the way
yeah yeah the one on the right's artwork
the one on the left is real picture one
on the
hey i bet those guys shoot what i want
to know is that guy right there that guy
right there has a smile on his face like
something good is going on yup oh yep
thick ropes
fun toads that are actually no fantasy
so what is it okay i don't know i don't
know what it is people have explained
it's about a hundred times i don't know
yet
because
someone said like fighters can make a
lot of money off because they think old
like clearly name it like this yeah
you're naming like this off of whatever
like yeah you can do that it depends you
gotta do that i get it oh really it
depends yeah for your old fights the
problem is with gold fights is ufc owns
the rights to it uh so you can what you
should do another fight is realistic
street fights
yeah you want your name and likeness yes
do an animation sell that yeah because i
never signed another brain i never
signed up for my rights to them at all
wow yeah oh wow amazing that's good yeah
so then or just so those are mine and
brian's no fun toads all right there's
one at 700.000
that's that's the one we bought i bought
those for 120 dude they're now it's
seven seven four hundred dollars yes but
that's one thing we own 50 each yeah
when did you buy it dude when did you
buy it oh of course it was hard
and i own 50 each and right now look we
bought our toads at 120 each that's
there's two fights
what do you think we're gonna make
more than that
quarters
what a [ __ ] round they're running out
of those they don't even exist
no what no
that's the insane [ __ ] it's just like i
know and digital they're ready you can't
run out of something that doesn't exist
no because anyone can make one yeah yeah
and then they put them i make my own
after nfts your nf2 would sell yeah but
i want to keep them for me well let me
buy a couple no you can't give me
something give me something they're
limited no what are you gonna how are
you gonna make cause i wanna make the
there's there's a head kick i have it i
got you oh you got one there's another
one of me like with uh
with uh benson i have a whole team who
creates it yeah that's awesome man yeah
they're great
i didn't know where they were
they did uh they did over in walmart's
[ __ ] decapitation francis went like
for like 500 grand they did tony
ferguson they did uh
russell uh for the the quarterbacks of
the seahawks nice
you made nfts i see that down so there's
one where i'm looking over his face
yeah
so like the camera's facing me like
right away like you can see no there's
that one but there's another one too
dude look at that we're like it's it's
shin to the dome where his back is to
the to the
his back is to the camera josh how many
fights you have that one right there so
there's that one right there yeah that
one that's what i want right there
i want that one
maybe maybe more uh clear though you
know i had yeah i had i had
the imagination after that fight right i
had a [ __ ] golf ball-sized indention
in my shin i put a golf ball in it
because i just happen to have a golf
ball that i roll my i roll my feet down
i roll my feet on before i fight every
fight is that right
fight yeah and i put it i it was a golf
ball-sized indention in my [ __ ] chin
i put a golf ball in it i swear to you
just sat there wow i put my foot up like
this because the ball broke
no the shin just bent it basically like
just indented in chris came back yeah it
came back out but an hour later two
hours later after the fight it swell up
to the softball size i couldn't even put
my pants on i put a softball on i
couldn't put my hands down hey chris
this is a bowling ball it was so big
that my pants won't go down anymore
chris you're going to flinch at this
idea a little bit but go with it okay i
want you to send your son to josh to
train to be a cage fighter okay
send him tomorrow like i love him
he's one and a half does that work
is he only one and a half that's what he
can't even jump yeah
i say jump and he goes he just puts his
arm yeah my kid goes like that it's
[ __ ] you got to get him in gymnastics
right now i know yeah actually we did we
departed right away
one and a half yeah one and a half yes
we brought him there it's so cute dude
he does a little beam and he holds on
and he boxing
maybe even put them in like the ninja
warrior stuff i'm telling you right now
kids love it oh yeah
yes they [ __ ] love it you have one
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah does uh yeah yeah
does your son jump yet can you jump yet
tiger or boss no i know tiger can jump
yeah yeah but not boston uh tiger he's
dunking boston uh yeah
so uh are we doing are we doing are we
trying for a girl what are you doing oh
yeah you're done you're trying to grow
wow how many did you have
none oh i thought you said you had kids
no no you have to well you have two kids
yeah six
do you really 14. you're lying he said
he was 58 18. no he has two girls right
no well i mean just
[Laughter]
how many kids you have two geez one on
the way one step three yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
you did you announce it on here no i
didn't forget you just told me not to
say anything oh
he said people know he said people know
i shouted out from the rooftops oh brian
collins he's got another one on the way
people go in
yeah it's like a beginning of a musical
kid's 20 year 80 uh no it's not going to
feel weird you know why he's going to be
dead he can't feel anything he's 74 dude
didn't feel anything when you're done
hey you have kids i'm like yeah i got 16
of them yeah i'll be 74. it is over
there so it's shredded
no they're like
they're gonna be like oh it's cool your
grandpa supports you and all this [ __ ]
no that's my dad dude yeah that's true
but i'm going to be uh i'll have to just
get your nuts out how much trt do you do
so like
i've been trying to trt but i will you
will you will
get on i'm 54. i will i think i will
eventually get on the trt i will i'm not
yet not yet
i still work out every day i still feel
good about myself
my energy's good that's how i feel i'm
one of those guys i'm on a natural high
like all day yeah i don't the thing is i
have a lot of energy and everything is
good my game's good i'm gonna
i just flew here [ __ ] from ireland
last night yeah got here at like 12 30.
running the car sat in a [ __ ] rental
car place for two hours got the goddamn
rental car go to the hotel checked in
got some food [ __ ] here with you guys
yeah you're leaving here at six in the
morning tomorrow [ __ ] oh you're one
of those guys one of those guys one of
those guys i just go jealous of those
[ __ ]
chris are you would you ever do trt
if you guys are doing it
that's the thing i mean that's not the
reason no no we all get you jumping off
bridges you're like yo [ __ ] it let's go
yeah lost boy style right right you go i
go you like you [ __ ] with your endocrine
system just i call it hurt but yeah no
listen
i'll get on the turf you sniff it or
what no man you know what you do you
gotta shoot it in your ass i'll help you
oh yeah yeah i like that kind of stuff
you you do it yourself or you're getting
like
your friends
testosterone you let me pull your pants
down and get it in the muscle it'll make
your hair you pick a spiral on the wall
we're gonna go
i heard you can get trt though with the
with the lotion yeah you can do it yeah
that's the i'm more of that i don't want
to stick meals on myself yeah yeah it
doesn't get as effective as effective
dude i'll take my dude
you can also plant you can get a uh uh
like a pill planted so it's time
released oh you do it once in the day
where do you put it in your in your anus
no they inject it on your arm and you
crack it you go
oh it's like your hair it's like it's
like the female birth control they put
it like they put it in your arm and then
you've got to get the in this one let's
do an nft of the anus i don't know
just just a little gadget always all
brown chin yes i still got the
the coughs oh tell me man
it's been how long now
i mean
last week with you guys man
thursday i was talking like crap friday
i'm like i called him up i'm like i
cannot make it man
he's like oh yeah i'm sure with bellator
we have to get coca testing i'm telling
you yeah
i've had three in the last three days
you ever have to perform when you have
the flu
i'm practicing three years ago the
sickest i've ever been i called the
manager i'm like dude i i gotta cancel
you dude you have a soldier what
happened you you went on stage sick oh
the sickest i've ever been
i know when you had to go on stage when
you had foot and mouth [ __ ] right yep
yeah yeah he had kids
that's kid [ __ ]
first and he had to go in and it's so
good
from kids 50 years old with foot and
mouth 45 but yeah it was terrible it was
that long ago yeah well we were in san
antonio bad psoriasis i was covered in
surroundings you look like you freddie
cruz but i i had i had swine flu and i
performed that's right hey why do you
get all the diseases
i went on i went on stage once very very
very sick uh maybe two or three times
you were fine when you're on stage
you're good when you get off it's just i
was i had the flu once and i was
yeah i couldn't hear myself it was all
clogged you know i'm trying to three
years
[Music]
that is yeah i had the flu and i had to
do and i was in new orleans the worst
place to be with the flu that's when i
did it and i [ __ ] still guess what i
still crunch but it was all good no but
i know i couldn't hear the crowd but i i
saw them they were jumping up and down
it was fun they were just like what the
[ __ ] people were pulling off their scalp
i don't know if that's going to happen
so you don't have to add that to the
story
nope you don't have to add that to the
story let's go i'm all hairy down there
what can i do speaking of pulling off
your scalp listen gentlemen the holidays
came early because manscape the leading
men hygiene brand has launched a new
product it's all new ultra premium body
wash and two in one shampoo conditioner
body wash two in one daddy
it gives uh yourself the gift of
beautiful skin hair balls this holiday
season i guarantee your hygiene routine
will never be the same go to
manscape.com cfc for 20 off and free
shipping make sure you're feeling and
smelling prepared for a little action
under the mistletoe it doesn't have a
pump top infused with aloe vera and sea
salt to keep your skin feeling clean oh
dude you like coconut questions you like
coconut water yeah yeah i mean it has
that in it what you have to nourish your
skin whoa yep how about
dude don't forget they got that 4.0
lawnmower so you can shave down your
nuts yup give it a philly fade dude
whatever you want to do go to
manscape.com promo code i'm sorry
manscape.com cfc that's swimsuffin free
shipping with the code manscape.com cfc
clean up your candy cane this year with
manscape that is another penis reference
yeah all right did you get the new uh
shampoo uh
yes i got it nice
tired of the running mill podcast check
out congratulations no sorry what check
out you're welcome no it's not called
your welcome
moana [ __ ] song you're welcome hey
you guys tired of frowning if you're
tired of frowning and you live near the
florida naples area damn it brian counts
at all the common weirdest cities off
the hills
here's brian here's brian when he's in
his city people should have this is
there looking at the real city that's
you
dude
no that's how everybody is
that's my show
deep in the distance
jim whatever you do take his microphone
foam and just wash it
hey bro
he's gotta come with his own or
something like that
on my pocket
it's like just white oh you know what i
love christmas
oh the costume [ __ ]
yeah these two are savages right there
she's the she's the she's the hands down
the best female fighter in the village
what would happen if they both fight
hands down best females oh don't wear
that hat though unless you're a painter
or snapchat her boyfriend
wonder it has to be though yeah um
probably yes she's amazing
yeah what is she like 58 now gosh
she had a baby at 51. she didn't know
she had one of 47. what's her name had
one of nature dude freaking uh lucy liu
how old is she bob did lucy lou have a
baby at 51 or does she adopt one at 51
i'll check right now his name is van
hunt dude i'd wear a hat like death my
name was van hoof that's my boy right
there frankie [ __ ] edward i just
don't want him to see him i think he
wins tonight i hope he does i love
cheeto man she's a guy she doesn't but
he cheers my baby she does the sneaker
headquarters he's a great kid but sorry
man she's like what are you laughing
about
you want to hear something funny
kristen just sent me a a video of calvin
um seeing me on this show and he's
saying
and then it shows brian and he says
pop-pop that's what he calls
grandpa
smart kid
he's saying pop-pop
oh [ __ ] oh man you're kidding he's smart
right i'm gonna scold your kid dude
you're gonna take your hand to his face
my my kid's tall as [ __ ] for his age
he's tall chris goes one and a half yeah
dude boston is looking for spawn well
let's do it let's do it i get it i gotta
text satso goes sassa goes
you have the sweetest sport and chris
goes yeah he's way sweeter than brian's
kid was at that age
and then i get a text i get a random
text from chris and just out of nowhere
it just says
you love your kids six out of ten
yeah six out of ten [ __ ] six
out of ten i love my kid ten out of ten
or eleven all right ten all right not
crazy dude no we have more though huh oh
thanks man you have more
this guy's a real one yeah so i like
beating [ __ ] you want me to open it
for you
what if he's like thanks man
i'm gonna get some cheese i don't give a
[ __ ]
is it oh cheese mike brat
you want one
i'm all right right now
no i'm done
dude
so bro oh brian how are you money
because i took chandler
oh you lost him again dude he owes me
like 300 000
this is why i just bet he gives me three
hundred thousand dollars
i wonder what it is for real like
oh really you guys have ever run like
two million
what you guys ever really ever pay
oh yeah i paid him last time all right
yeah where
[Applause]
[Laughter]
endless bad so let me know right you're
good you're good at knowing things huh
you're good at betting
look this is the betting line though
i've taking dogs here see this would be
this would be a ball with canelo i would
take colby only based on the fact that
it was two two going to the fifth last
degree and if colby wrestles this time
it's gonna be a lot closer fighting
people you know what i hate betting on
the fights and picking because it gets
back to the hold on holby
that's honestly colby coming in that's
who brian cowan thinks he looks like a
little bit i would like to look like him
yeah there you go bro you're you're
you're one step away from looking and
you're both far
you're both right 58 years old you're
not far right dude yeah get on something
all right far right brian's far right
i'm not you're far right are you no i'm
i'm very middle of the road you're far
right i mean does santa's 20 you're
saying that all because you live here
enough i'm as close to i'm probably
right
you're trying to tell the line right it
says
these days you've looked me in the eyes
and you've said gay [ __ ] married you've
said that you look me in the eyes and
you said gage should not marry you said
that you'd look me in the eyes and i go
brian that's not and you said i don't
give a [ __ ]
and i was like brian what are you
spreading rumors gays shouldn't marry no
you're spreading rumors
no i'm pro-gay marriage justice jesus
christ
you better clear this up right [ __ ]
now bro i'm brian seriously he's like
yeah i'm actually i'm actually pretty
libertarian about it
you're both you're both you're you're
both you're middle that's what it should
be
i will say if you don't believe in jesus
you're going to hell forever anybody
else that's very extreme wow
you're a christian what i'm a soldier of
christ
i was just a soldier of christ i wish i
was i wish i was i was just oh my gosh
rampage soldier of god that's his dad
chin i was in i was at the come on
cheeto wow dude jameson's uh distillery
on wednesday
they do one you can't get in the states
get the bite online it's called crested
crescent james went there with james
we're out there
with his brother
did you do the mixology class yeah yeah
yeah
we did the guinness poor class and we
got started guinness yeah
do the mix they say you guys go to uh
ireland or dublin
do the mixology classes they show you
how to make you know they try to make
the
what's old-fashioned and
one uh
the swi the sour one what's it called
what's the shower oh whiskey sour yeah
for sure next time oh i was gonna say
chris have you uh done stand up in
dublin
in ireland yeah no have you yes oh
amazing
2 p.m in the afternoon hold my video of
2 p.m 4 p.m 6 p.m 8 p.m watch watch this
you can listen to this thing because
it's like you can listen to this did you
and big john get hammered
we didn't we got pretty smart the whole
i think though
no so look at this video right there
this is him the other one the other one
the one extra the james gallagher one i
just started following you
the next one that one right there that
see james right there in the middle the
one in the middle yes
what's this this kid this is walkout
listen to the crowd
that's the crowd singing the song that's
what the song oh wow
what song is it
they're singing it not sweet caroline
who's this guy that's british it's free
it's uh
[ __ ] i just i just is it coming to
america dude it is so crazy what the
heck from desire is it neil diamond
coming to america no
cheetos such a fun watch watch this
they're [ __ ] out of control
this is
twelve thousand fans
best crowds i've ever had yes and i was
worried they wouldn't get
people in ireland just start singing
though they'll be hanging and then just
start singing that's part of their
culture dude did you know that brian
they just start singing don't don't talk
to me about irish history or other or
anything about his it's not history it's
just how they are i'm not hearing
anything hey but you talked to us about
cars and fashion i know
but are you here question about a car
[ __ ] is that a car i'll own i'll i'll
i'll get it right name uh a type of new
ferrari go a type of new friar no no
you're stalling see you don't ask the
question to the question i know would
you want you want to type in the new
ferrari yeah give me a model of the new
phrase spider 2.3
what is a great point average huh
yeah i said a spider
no spider would mean it's a convertible
that's not a type of ferrari that's cool
no i'm saying you said you want you want
the you want the like like your name on
the name of it yeah uh
[ __ ] testarossa
did you say a contesterosa i said
testosterone now you could have said a
countach
i'm invested in this conversation thank
you tribe because i i grew up as a fan
of countach as a kid my favorite so they
they hate the release of them i go oh
i'll take i saw the i saw that and i hit
my car guy goes oh bubba off the lot
they're 1.3 million unbelievable
you go like this have a good day oh i
went okay have a good day so what's up i
just didn't respond back the problem is
you
if you had the money you would actually
buy that
i mean i mean papa could figure it out
he could he could buy it but he would be
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you put a band-aid over your cheek
and driving i put spinners on it yep but
but and then i'm saying you're gonna
have that that's two that's too much why
why do you especially for that i'm so
fascinated with why the ferrari stuff
you can have two coming i'll give you a
breakdown of it off here why i did that
okay but it's a business plan i
understand and i like what i appreciate
about you let's go you actually drive
your car driving [ __ ] out you drive the
[ __ ] out of it
dude having a car sit there i mean
unless you jay leno you got 800 billion
dollars then okay there's certain cars
you want to sit there like you have a
law ferrari or like a certain like peace
does i guess
because they just it's like buying a
house and they just appreciate it right
right right frankie's 40 for christ's
sake shut up shut your hand i love him i
just i just don't want to see him take
care how would you do against frankie
right now silence if i get if i give you
24 week notice you and frankie
that's a good fight together forever man
i think justin
i'm not going to give you an answer all
right i'm not going to use a lot smaller
look look here's the what's more when
you say you like me because i'm not fake
i'm not fake i'm going to give you a
fake answer yeah i really actually like
if we were fighting right now he'd beat
me
yeah well he's gonna be worried
if if we were fighting when i was
training it's in your prime yeah no no
great [ __ ] fight what would you trade
with us at aka yeah i know this yeah
but i don't know how you feel i would
say i would do well against him i think
probably would edge him out but that was
that was i also had a lot more
experience bigger too i was big he
fought 55. he won the ufc title 55 yeah
down to 45. i guess bj [ __ ] pennies
next to frankie's family before that
fight where kate's side when i'm
frankie's fine when he looks at me goes
do you think he got this i go i have
them winning they start celebrating yeah
he got [ __ ] up so bad i went out there
to help him train for the second fight i
fought i trained with him southpaw the
whole [ __ ] i love you two weeks of camp
dude first guest ever on food truck
first guest really yep i didn't know
that he can't he's a stud man give me
great pizza on jersey shore is one of
the greatest [ __ ] people i've ever
met my whole life yeah
the best human beings one of the best
people ever the best ever that's awesome
his wife him his like his kids that's
why this is his family that's why they
are [ __ ] absolutely amazing but this
is why this is why
cheeto is such a great guy one of my
favorite people he's so [ __ ] nice
josh i don't want to see him i don't
want to see him oh real quick before you
go against cheeto he was fighting to pay
for surgery for his daughter who was
sick so shut your [ __ ] mouth and
prove her cheeto yeah i love him but i
love fighters but i just don't want i i
don't want frank yeager to take any more
damage yeah i know but afraid he takes
him down it's gonna be over oh and
cheeto is he from ecuador yeah dude he's
tom cruise out there they have
billboards of him every building he's
just got to wrestle freaking castles
in ecuador like he's like tom cruise he
can't walk the streets wow
they have massive like murals
fighting's so big there huh
come on frankie wrestle see i like this
guy's tattoos yeah they're all over
there it is there it is come on great
take down defense jon
who's this girl oh that's joyce rice who
she's half black half korean joyce
rice what a great mix she can sing i
can't hear her but she can see that's
for the canelo card
the walk out starting it starts at nine
it's only 8 30.
i don't know we'll see wow but by the
time they walk this national island's
about 10 minutes yeah and then when they
walk out you know 10 15. yeah i'm okay
with that brad garrett's uh
oh
come on played brad's club come on
frankie
i have not know brian i've heard it
what's that book i've heard it's
yeah he's the [ __ ] i love him keith i'll
always be loyal too now that guy's he's
great yeah the best
and and good clubs
a lot of the wise guys in salt lake wise
guys vegas is great and vegas is tricky
man unless you're like jay leno or some
[ __ ] yeah
that's not i mean not for me but yeah
okay no it's not no it is true you know
what i'm saying that's right how the
[ __ ] am i gonna be you can do [ __ ]
nine million things you also compete
with like celine dion yeah well that's
what i mean yeah yeah yeah yeah they're
like jesus at the tropicana
the michael jackson hologram was going
on
when you were there yeah all right he's
not good for frank nothing no i see
michael jackson hologram or me he's fine
yeah he's fine there i know
oh my god
and this [ __ ] fight i can't handle it
it's too much for it my mind's gone down
dude he's trying to get his words out
it's a problem sorry that was [ __ ]
hilarious i need to concentrate on both
fights before you bet against caleb
plant yeah uh his daughter
passed away when she was like one of my
friends you're picking up deaths and so
much you better go how dare you okay
okay so uh he promised he'd be world
champion when he won the world
championship belt went straight from the
arena to the gravesite wow this is not
the fight i love caleb i'm sorry that's
why i wish i wasn't better
though but if but if canelo knocks him
out brian need my [ __ ] money i know
that i'm aware now i'm ahead bubba i'm a
head i'm a head fourth grader i know
when you wouldn't got jesus talking
about you owe me three three
hundred grand
what fight did we bet on last companion
uh the uh oh i took corey the underdog
okay so
think i'll do it i'll i'll take gusman
really i'm gonna i owe you four grand
yeah i'll take guzman for granted
you want to double up
the whole thing yeah yeah jesus christ
all right but i can definitely see kobe
winning i see cool we want to do i'd
rather break even though you know all
right i think i think um gets the dom
but i think i can see kobe winning oh
dude the bet will be december 10th when
we do this again and you got [ __ ] uh
oh my god he's kicking these out of them
yeah
they're really taking it from all angles
here
chris that's good you should still come
on i should do color commentary yeah
i feel like those guys that are like i
mean they're in football and baseball
like joe buck those guys are here we go
bottom of the night
those guys are kind of going to the
right
yeah
also like like journalists and like
those like like suit and tie guys yeah
yeah you guys got like pat mcfee you got
like rogan like yeah yeah yeah they're
just taking them i mean hey what's going
on
there's no charges though it's just
there's no like evidence of anything but
have you seen what he's doing like
portnoy is going hard on the pain so
apparently this is this is a cup first
of all he's showing all the texts he got
the dm's he got from that one girl the
one girl who said that like she kept
saying no he goes then why would she
text me afterwards and try and hook up
with me dude there was a heart i don't
know exactly what happened he's got so
much he goes hard because he's got all
the and now apparently he's no punk the
owner of this is what i heard the owner
and some investors of business insider
shorted the stock or something it
dropped like point two billion dollars
of the company that bought bar stool
yeah yes that's very suspect to me yeah
they're marry [ __ ] i mean it's like
you know you know yeah it's like wait a
minute well like like what noise is like
always said he goes they've been trying
to cancel me for years yeah he's like so
this is the first time is that and then
he's also like super
kind of right and he's been on fox news
and stuff so when those woke lefts go
after you they're going to come man
that's where they find you that's what
here's what's inside about him he's
already made his money you know what
he's like yeah he's already he already
sold the company he's out yeah but he
doesn't like his politics he's not going
out without a fight i'll tell you that
well that's what aaron rodgers said he
was like the left is going to try and
cancel me the right's going to champion
me i don't give a [ __ ] about any of them
exactly yeah [ __ ] i'm still giving me
the quarterback i'm still making
millions that's right you can be mvp
this year can't win green bay is not
gonna come journalists spend eight
months you can't if you're in rogers
you're not gonna take out he's too good
he's undeniable no yeah i i honestly
will be good i honestly believe in
between basically between them and the
rams being the champs agree rams just
got von miller i don't know oh i know
but i want who's going where's the obj
going
i haven't cheated on [ __ ] i think chiefs
yeah i could see that i think you're
going to have money though
a little bit
i think right yeah
she's family
von miller as in middle linebacker yeah
outside linebacker
no
position oh
odor black and junior just got released
they cut it by the browns they cut them
there they released them why he wasn't
playing he's hurt and then there's like
toxins
they say
come on bro he's like oh my god
in the nfl really [ __ ] who would have
thought
guys they pick it's just hilarious kayla
best beard in combat sports come on some
of those dagger stands have great beards
but i like yeah
dude your boy uh frankie edgar is is
doing just fine he's been fighting for
400 years he's a [ __ ] star
does he still have his ufc gym out there
in new jersey yeah yeah he's opening
alone right now the one that he opened
up in jersey the first one the new oh
well they heard it was in a weird area
it was extreme
so now they they've he's they've they've
gifted him a second one i know bj's do
well in hawaii [ __ ] his are killing he's
got five now yeah really
six really
well only certain guys jim's crush
doesn't biz being have one orange county
sure he's got i think he's got two they
have two did they give you one
you have one norcal
yeah and then they are you talking about
uh the ufc huh yeah well they yeah ufc
they have to partner with the fighters
like bisping has one bj penn has one all
right i don't know is this the main uh
yeah that's the main box that's kayla
plant versus uh this i'm telling you
right now i'm gonna say it again caleb
plant is going to surprise the fight i
hope you're right brian he will he's
he's a stud i didn't realize he's such a
star he will surprise us he will
surprise us but he had to win no he's
not going to get the win but he's going
to surprise the [ __ ] yeah he will he
will it's going to be it's like one of
those andy ruiz
situations it's underestimating how good
uh [ __ ] no i'm not but i think this
is gonna i'll tell you how about i say
this canelo finishes okay tell me what
you think of this oh i don't know i
think i think this is the toughest hold
on what about i say this though
hold on
because i'm fired
no bro i don't eat that [ __ ] you just
stopped there to get a diet coke you got
it's a [ __ ] coffee thank you that
looks like you know what i mean it's
like we connect immediately
you gotta you got a quarter pounder and
a die cut wrap things like that
and i ate it sheepishly before i came in
yeah he had like one of those it was
like one of those ice frap coffee things
listen to me right now brennan this is
the toughest fight canelo's the guy
needs to take his money
like why wear mascara if you're gonna do
that closely no i don't i don't get it's
so interesting some of the people have
to wear the masks
yeah you're all in or you're out all of
them are zero dude when they saw the
emmys when like it's like the stars
didn't have to do it but the people who
were hanging how about seth rogens what
are we doing
they got so mad absolutely so good [ __ ]
it it's so stupid look at this
and i got the facts i'm not even [ __ ]
i'm bulletproof i'm bulletproof
[ __ ]
what a stupid thing to say
i was pretending i was looking for i
missed the fire strike rockets rocks
you're bad rocks or no not bad toughest
fight of canelo's career i just said it
out loud
oh tougher than triple g yeah get out
all right that's right dude this guy
jeez
oh sorry the one
chris that's not relevant no the guy
ripped his pants twice hey is it weird i
kind of hope canelo loses because at my
house they all just suck his dick
from the same hometown
are you gonna get into your house
tonight and she hears this oh dude she
was like what dude jimmy is your whole
family
made when he fights my entire house so
your house right now is packed packed oh
you're happy because they're from the
same home but your wife speaks to an
italian and uh spanish because she's
half italian correct so is my son what
else dude that's amazing okay well
calvin katie speaking what do you want
my son says three sentences all right
uh to be fair my my two-year-old says
chambees and says zombies dude kid rock
looks weird marlon
dude post malone got thick kid rod what
the [ __ ] mickey rook is weird dude who
is that oh that's one of those latin why
does he have the thriller jacket on is
that mickey rourke i don't know who that
is i just said hey so we were in london
for about
here we go
oh he's a rapper yeah yeah huge i heard
he was huge he was with adele i think so
no he just said with like uh i'm saying
though oh oh really i think
well that's a little strange skepta yeah
skeptic he's a huge rapper he's got an
album
yeah
like other
people he's huge yeah
of lebron james now oh okay
agent of lebron james you say lebron
james agent
like he's from [ __ ] like it's lord of
the rings hey did you he she is with the
agent of lebron james now
hey did you know what i meant though his
name's rich paul dude that's rich that's
good
he's a rapper well rich paul okay well
there they are together and she's lost
all the waiting people she lost all that
well people are mean to her because she
lost weight oh how dare you get healthy
bro people are [ __ ] heaven forbid you
actually slim out liz
i'll take it from here yeah they are
[ __ ] beef holy shoot who's that
that's canelo's girlfriend you don't
become the pound champion of the world
and not have a dime piece does she have
makeup
that's her daughter to the left there
1919 huh third round to side
come on friends
get a take down it's tough not to ruin
frankie but i [ __ ] have cheated
sorry i gotta be frankie that's fair i
gotta pee my pants all right go ahead
you have to go ready here we go
oh we're gonna throw frankie oh i
should've too
i should've done it
i'm so sorry
good thing you have a bag
boy what a night canelo and camaro there
it is right there yeah
did you hear camaro singing
canelo look at frankie with his [ __ ]
did you hear that josh camaro said he
wants to fight canelo
match bad idea they asked uh cannellini
just like that's murder he starts
laughing murdered
he'll get murdered oh these guys won't
do it well you know francis wants to
fight uh
fury so i understand that me too i do i
understand yeah i understand they'll
make money i'm not saying i'm not saying
when you're talking about tomorrow's
guys
cadella's ridiculous yeah francis fury
i'm like i'll watch that
just like he was starch oh who's being
stupid
i'm not going to know
yeah go take a [ __ ] come back come on
bro come on yeah take a [ __ ]
but but francis fury i'm like yeah
francis lance i can see that
[Music]
you're being disrespectful to fury right
now no i'm not though because francis
hits so hard if he lands it could be a
problem
so does our boy a wilder wilderness
don't stop stop stop talking about
wilder
well let's talk about wyatt though okay
if you want to compare speed though
difference france got he's faster twitch
muscle francis way better chance to
knock out wilderness yes exactly wilder
francis no
no what i'm saying though is no what i'm
saying is that francis though has a
better chance of knocking out fuhrer
fury oh i disagree i'm not saying better
chance but i'm saying that he can do it
if you're here because it's faster
will get there sooner wilder than have
the fundamentals that fury does wilder
will get hit and if francis hits you i
don't give a [ __ ] what ounce no what i'm
talking about he's gonna knock him out
but what i'm talking about fury i'm just
gonna be tough to hit fury francis can
hit him though right if he doesn't he's
faster than wilder that's what i'm
saying if you want to compare fury and
wilder if you want to kill the two right
i'm saying that in ghana in ghana will
be able to touch
both fury speed wise he'll get there
faster than wilder would
and the power translates in that speed i
think a better fight
but wilder will go 12 rounds and still
knock you out in the 12th round yeah
francis will not you but you know that's
why francis didn't sign a deal with the
ufc yeah back good yes get your [ __ ]
looks does that count does that count no
yeah it's a takedown
come on judges it might why don't you
[ __ ] judge your hooks frankie
look frankie is going to win this fight
i'm going to count oh he's down i
haven't been paying attention he's
moving backwards i don't know man he's
been doing he's just got dropped out oh
did he get dropped that's what kevin
says sometimes
well dude look at the odds minus 550 for
a cheeto he's beating the [ __ ] out of
him guys yeah we're not paying attention
all right maybe you're right but i'm
with you i thought frankie was doing
better too
but we didn't pay attention god damn it
hey but you know that that's why francis
you called it out you caught the odds
though but guess what it's still one one
is that much minus 550 though i know it
still won't be how tall is judo five
he's probably five five
they stopped it immediately
oh he's pissed at him early stoppage
though
[ __ ] i mean i don't know man let him
stop she was such a good guy though
frankie is so good
tell me josh that's why francis didn't
sign a long-term deal with the ufc yeah
because his team wants him to
fight cyril gone win that and then have
the option to fight fury or wilder hey
you know who's out right now right
what'd you say
you think i mean you don't think you oh
i don't think he's a stick around to
fight hamzad
that's about oh no well you know that's
crazy but that's
that's a bad hit hell yeah that ref has
a flat top in the canelo fight oh
my boy robbie at barstool was
interviewing dana and goes people say
you just you're just trying to devalue
nate by giving them hamzad
and dana's like what i'm trying to value
him he lost his last fight did we
devalue him there when he fought leon
edwards he's like fight to fight and and
i agree with this point he's like at a
certain point we gotta see if we can
hang at this higher level yeah finally
if you can't if you're if you can't be a
guy like comsat you probably shouldn't
be here but i've said though but i said
sure he wants to continue to fight the
top guys that's i think that that ship's
sailed he's done when it comes to that
name
i don't know what i'm saying
and if nick get out of his contract
he'll fight logan
two of them i agree with him yeah and
they're gonna make way more money doing
that
were you the one to break that news nate
uh jake yeah
i'm i'm not saying that that's gonna
happen what i'm saying is i really
believe it's gonna happen that's where
you make the most money that's where
that exactly
i must say i wasn't committed to like oh
you know what i'm telling you i don't i
don't for you know i'm a jake and logan
fan they're friends but i don't like
jake versus how are you fans he won this
dude
i know i know logan well i don't know
jake well logan's you wouldn't i know
you so what was the legend what was the
logan thing with the japanese
hanging thing 20 20 years old i don't
know we all make upstairs
that's business okay
good guy
bro but i'll tell you what i don't like
jake versus nate that's a terrible fight
for jake
yeah terrible fight what about was jake
for his neck
terrible fight even worse why they're
monsters officers do this the volume
they put in like [ __ ] through you
wait who boy would they make money
talking about jake jake versus nate diaz
jake and nate um
terrible fight for jake
yeah you mean jake jake paul yeah
yeah and they that's what we think is
gonna happen really he has one fight
left on his contract they want to give
nate hamzad nick nate's like [ __ ] you
take the money
and and you think nate diaz will win you
don't do you own horses
waiting for someone to say something
are you going to do the nas that i mean
the uh no hey are you are you relaxed
not are you
nas lilacs
nas lil x hey hey hey bit killer jones
dude [ __ ] hey bro it was about to be
rose central i was cocking all of my i'm
ready dude
hey are you bert reynolds from mars
attacks bro bring it up chad bro bro hit
it hit it are you bert
reynolds from boogie night dude why are
you dressed like that if it's a roaster
you know i like fashion yeah
chin hit it dude
i i i stink
reynolds from [ __ ] martial
and i i guarantee
that
he doesn't bounce for me he [ __ ] it he
[ __ ] it
i'm still on it bro
i'm still on it i'm killing it bro df
horses because if you don't i play video
games i have horses in the video games
then take that no this is [ __ ] ill
are you a barker you know
i got i got a costume [ __ ] anyway thank
you i have other stuff put the fight
back on please chin for god's sake the
final oh yeah for god's sake yeah yeah
you do look like brett reynolds from uh
okay so it is 2 45 in the first round
for canelo versus uh who cares about
that oh yeah he was all-time oh [ __ ] kim
just dropped him oh my god
half of the tory he's good man oh wow
you did do it
victories
what's that show she says sorry strong
guys with a broken heart you'll see
champ right there the champ is in the
house
hey chris is that your own merch oh yeah
comic-con no no no i sorry strong guys
yeah dude well i'm strong i know i'm
starting to break your heart all right
i don't get the reference
what are you saying no because i work
out
heavy oh
guys there's a new guy in town i'm sorry
about your heart that's fine i broke
your heart okay
who do you work out with myself that's
lonely issues you know so where do you
live i live in uh in west hollywood
wollywood bollywood
ah no i live in uh west hollywood yeah
oh you do yeah yeah makes sense his
neighbors yeah
his neighbor's serena williams um
yeah you know yeah she was yeah yeah
yeah she moved she was never there right
she moved in and i moved i just i used
his neighbor oh she was never there
though i [ __ ] love her yeah she's
great never [ __ ] never saw her once
was never there probably greatest in his
player of all time
yeah
if you care about tennis sure oh wow you
know what i respect how you said that i
like that i just feel like that was more
of a burn i felt like he's so
independent but you're back in that [ __ ]
right you guys are not going to watch
this fight but your backhanding [ __ ]
right my backhand you're back in here
backhand's crazy all right
show me oh wow oh come on dude hey most
most dominant fighter of all time khabib
uh most dominant fighter dominant yeah
anderson silver in his prime no no
no thinking about chelsea think about
the warhead with chelsea still
like that fight was close up until oh
what about damien maya yeah
later on in history no no no we're not
that's prime anderson
that homeboy did from new york
no but he really did i'm just saying i'm
playing with advocacy just in case you
won the first round hold on hold on hold
on guys no no the judges gave him the
first time
i believe it was justin in his prime
anderson silva
not better conor won one round because
you know just can he press and punch
himself outside he fought chill song
around thorough and lost
he lost a round
he said he didn't lose a round is so
great you don't have a dot on your nose
yeah i know that i do because i had it
no you know what it is have you ever had
the older brother the little brother
situation go on where like you know like
one guy can just smash the other and let
they just keep going at it yeah no that
that thing on your nose
is it's [ __ ] from kissing fighter's ass
that's what it is you know the thing on
your nose is careful [ __ ] okay if i just
want to be real you know i like to be
real okay but they're carrying on your
nose i'm gonna get mad it's all good but
i want to be respected that's something
is this the real side of the table
because i feel like this is that's what
you're saying it's wrong
you know it's wrong what you're saying
knows what's going on
it's [ __ ] yeah
from kiss and fighters [ __ ]
no it's not because tell them what it is
it's
frostbite i had a little spot from
kissing the fighter's [ __ ]
the dermatologist the dermatologist said
stop kissing
fire oh boy cody garbrandt he's fighting
i got i got my car in france what's
going to come back to this i want to
come back to this that's
at all and then you got uh
this one but that card is good it has a
tesla look at the tassels
look at caleb plant landing
look at the tassels
that's cool with my cowboy shirt that
would be really cool look at kayla plant
look at caleb plant
keeping his opportunity the worst
commentary
he's gotta stop showing his commentary
uh caleb plant look at that oh
i shot my plant though [ __ ] told you
guys you guys keep talking he's a blade
nobody's disappointed body shot
nobody's disagreeing with you i killed
his [ __ ]
he's huge yes he is and he's not here
enough
and he's hard to hit brian no you're
talking like we disagree with you these
guys both disagree these guys
[Laughter]
look at this look at this
kayla plants not hearing a peep out of
him at this point honestly it's
anybody's game it's the second round i
know it's the second round i know you're
a little too excited oh [ __ ] he
forfeited i don't know how he's going to
play out we'll see how it plays out
cotton
look at how plain keeps out there he's a
[ __ ] great boss espn
the tassels are there to distract his
the opponent
dude look at this watch kayla plant
fight guys dude it's the same
round yeah you know and we're also all
watching i know watch though he says but
i've got such an eagle eye
yeah that is true
i'm a sucker for uh promotion oh brian
you should yell at canelo to keep his
head i want it i wanna yeah
i love when you do that but dude look at
caleb plants footwork and how he gets
out of the pocket like that look at his
pop-pop pop
general general general
look at this hop up
just feeling you out feeling you out
look at this nothing no body shot
nothing nothing great hook god he's got
that [ __ ] great philly shell defense
no there's no philly there
is mexican traditional stuff no i'm
saying i'm saying kayla nope he's got
that philly show no he's got that uh
he's from knoxville tennessee it doesn't
matter he's still doing that philly's
show he's going inside the philly he's
fighting the way uh um mayweather did
look at this look at that look at that
look at that look at this oh
never got hit that much he's not getting
hit guys it's coming off his shoulder
you guys are going to shoot him but yeah
no i'm talking about caleb plant look at
this canelo
now this fight here with rose
is amazing
i don't like how many excuses whaley's
making coming into this
do does anyone dress worse than ring the
ring guys like the [ __ ] guys that
come out like this they have to dress
like that right right right yeah
says okay it's my buddy he wants me to
have you do this it's from it's from
this thing what is this what is this
what's this the uh the
the hangover oh
oh don't act like that's a small movie
don't act like you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're right well which one of the
three guys were you in the house
hey i don't watch it oh no you were zac
hey guys hey hey george
samir says hello just like how he said
hello
hello hello hello
no
were you in the movie i'm a fan of yours
but i just didn't know what i'm saying
see how i get in the character right
away yeah that was really actually
impressive
at the wedding chapel oh you're in the
movie you're in the chapter it's it's
two minutes i got it it's great oh dude
my friend my friend hey my friend texas
oh your friends actually my parents
count
no he wants you to do he wants you
greatest two minutes ever of your life
he wants you to do this hold on
hold on you josh [ __ ] you josh thompson
[ __ ] you josh thompson brian
my friend's texting he wants you to he
wants you to there's no more brownie on
this side of the table buddy i'll [ __ ]
you up
he wants you to do this he says kiss a a
fighter's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you chris
[ __ ] you chris you do it no chris and
your friend didn't say that no my friend
said it i don't you're being shitty tell
me his friend's name right now speaking
of shitty he just texted me speaking of
[ __ ]
he's a fighter's [ __ ] he just texted
me what's his name tell me what your
friend's name is you're making it up uh
jail sonic you manage it
that was good quick on the fly
yeah that was great that was great
dude i'm just telling you keep saying
look at caleb plant
you should sell merch that says look at
caleb oh oh dump upper hook matt hey hey
hey hey
you know what it is also his body brian
likes how do you make it
brian
how do you let him talk you in these
type of
she's an animal though i know she's such
a different level man a different level
i think rose beats her though oh man i
want to get crypto.com i'm such a sucker
chris [ __ ]
like how much more entertaining is the
ufc high level than boxing
honestly
you hold up you tell me this is as good
as just engaging michael chandler
suck my that's true but i but but at
this level i love watching boxing no i
don't get wrong i [ __ ] love boxing i
know as far as entertainment value if
you have a young son someone hit me up
and said hey actually and that's obvious
i agree i have to that's obvious
to my production my producer for our
podcast hey hit him up with hey and
that's obvious wow that's obvious wow
yep i don't know what that means but i
have no idea what is it oh there's no
tell me tell me it means that that's
obvious i used to used to be a [ __ ] i
guess
oh yeah hit him out hit up with this
thing that's obvious chris you're using
a vine thing right is vice still around
no [ __ ] i don't even know brian was huge
on vine oh shut the [ __ ] up
chris god damn it chris hey this is not
i don't like that i'm being [ __ ] while
i'm watching this fight i can't i can't
come back with witty comebacks because
i'm too involved in the fight oh man but
if there weren't fights on i'd be
[ __ ] good yeah yeah but she needs
rosa whaley
well okay rose i always have rose but if
it's smart she wrestles rose because
she's so much stronger now and now what
about rosie you follow him
what's that you follow him
no i'm training her but yeah he's
training her right now she's wrapped up
she's going to wrestle rose
that's a big problem because now she's
going to wrestle because
if she wrestles with rose look
you look at the roses you look at rose's
uh
she slows down in the third fourth fifth
rounds
she's got knockout powers she'll see all
this stuff if willie wrestles running in
the first two rounds slows her down well
he's got any chance to be never
submitted i think she has a remember you
look at the fight right when she fought
uh joanna wayley
she lost the first two rounds yeah then
she just started taking it over and and
that's you're talking about joanna not
some chump yeah and roseman don't slow
down in the in the later rounds look
rose
roger knockout power though yeah
rose rose is phenomenal but i do think
if if you're in ways camp you say
wrestle wrestle russell use your
strength sure hey chris i don't like how
many colors you're i know i know are you
watching kale plants like like cats
catch canelo in the face
you watch this i have a question how you
going to buy a ferrari it's just like
gray with green are you watching you
like buy this sweater yeah like
everything else
in the first six rounds don't count
i'm telling you you're watching
greatness you're watching
two of the places how did you sit next
to these guys
i said i walked in and brandon's like no
you're right there there's a chris you
know how brandon was here last time god
damn this is a good yeah sit next to uh
you know mr cullerman
christopher
roddelia
rondelia
[Applause]
bring out burt reynolds there we go
there we go i just saw this uh
he hasn't touched
him i disagree dude he hasn't touched
him do you care plants on his back his
entire fight that's the thing he's on
his back
if you're the bigger fighter though
callum what you're the bigger fighter
yeah you get pushed around by guys yeah
he's not getting pushed around yeah he
is though he would be on his back
[ __ ] about angles come on
don't talk to me about angles if i fight
you guys
i don't stand i'm not in the center line
like you [ __ ] guys i'm not i'm not
down the pike i'm always catching angles
nothing brian it's nothing he's rolling
those shots right he's looking good
in the eye when you tell me that
nonsense
look me in the [ __ ] eye you tell me
that nonsense i'll be the center i like
you look at you i can't look at your
eyes
i love you too much legend i love it
this kid's crazy i like i like saying i
like being a little sassy with you josh
of course of course
oh man two great fights going on i know
at the same time this is kind of a
bummer it's a problem but you're
watching [ __ ] history with caleb
plant you got it look at this he's
catching them bob oh
oh my god oh
[ __ ] rolled it
i
baby i like that you think caleb pants
winning this fight he's right he's
winning this fight oh he's down on the
scorecard
he's not down is he yes 100 no yeah
okay now wait so you're talking because
you're talking about how canelo is
pushing him yes back guys
yeah and he's the bigger fighter right
right right but you said on his back
foot he'd be on his back foot i fight on
my back foot oops right though because i
was talking
so
so he he's on his back foot if he's
watch this
okay now we both can agree you made a
mistake and you did it twice and you did
the same exact device right so
back-to-back oops right now we don't
want to do that right right hey we don't
do that to each other no we don't do it
because we're brothers oh yes okay when
you do that what you're saying to me is
i'm not in your family yeah i am
and it's a re-run right yeah this just
happened there's a replay
everyone watched in slow motion so why
would you interrupt me during a replay
when i'm in the middle of the car
because you already saw it right okay so
that's kind of three oopsies in a row no
and that's so all right i'm just
watching this dave
what are you gonna say the great yeah
he's there he's always there he's always
these other ufc fights
hmm
he's not both right now
that's how much of the goat he is dude
he's not a private jet to the main event
how [ __ ] good is he he's great he's
great
he's great that last special was unreal
unreal you know who i heard uh new hour
is
the best you're gonna see really here's
louis c.k
oh the one he did i haven't seen it the
one that's what's come out oh that's the
new one yeah i heard it's
[ __ ] real we are
[Music]
that last one did you see the last one
yeah
yeah he was great it was great man it
was great yeah
like is that story true though
his friend yeah oh yeah that's true
brutal brutal man brutal yeah brutal
sad at this point it's anyone's fight
hey you know who you know who else i
hear has just a banging hour every club
i go to i go who has been in here they
name all the all our guys i go who has
the best hour you've seen every single
club thank you every single club chris
little but when they say chris
but after you
santino
really if dude no i mean i don't mean to
say really like that he's great no he's
my friend every single club owner goes
santino hands down
sanjito's last name first name oh
dumbest thing ever heard the dumbest
thing ever a friend named santino
i have a friend but he is not a ginger
bobby lee he's on that show uh with one
of dickie dave yeah andrew's great i
always told andrew i was like dude
it's going to happen later than you
think but you're going to [ __ ] kill
caleb and now he is he is it's happening
come on rose come on rose gloves let's
go rose
[ __ ] this [ __ ] up
she went a little over the top of the
whole chinese comments my eyes hurt too
because i kind of kind of rubbed me
around away i'm like come on like let's
just be real communist
she straight up says she she's a first
generation
american well she watched the
documentary
yeah i get it i get it
cats when i watch don't [ __ ] let's
just be real with people
oh what
i'm telling how much pressure is on
white whaley from the chinese not much
oh a lot of the government yeah
he's trying to just open up the
institute there like it's a lot
name another chinese fighter yeah
they're like oh yeah
jay and lang and then uh what else
there's a couple other girls there's a
couple girl female ones yeah a couple
really good girl females is that cheese
chris popping man this cheese is so good
honestly ooh that jacket's distracting i
brought this
who makes that jacket chris gossip it's
so hard to watch two fights at one time
it's impossible [ __ ] my eyes are going
crazy i know it's such a problem really
don't watch either oh my god
okay the plan is just making a mess you
shut up
[Laughter]
i'm a little sensitive about my [ __ ]
like burns no it's sensitive fighters
outside when you kiss them dude
for the [ __ ] no no i'm not gonna show
you nah the
all right be quiet you are healing up
fast though so what is it not bad right
yeah
i had to i had a like a like he has
sunspot she's like i don't like the way
it looks right now
it's cancer they burn it off no everyone
gets so it doesn't turn into cancer or
did they say it could be oh you got
punched in the cage
yeah really yes son i think they're
hustling you just get money no i've been
i had a couch come on rose come on rose
did you save it you should keep it keep
the keep the little thing on your nose
the wart no is a wart you got a word i
know it's like which but look at look at
[ __ ] rose namajunas give it back to
her
guess what rosanna jews better and she's
going to win this fight is it weird me
and chris have longer here than both of
them right now here comes her wrestling
you got it there it is
her triangle's filthy her arm bars are
good
curious about her leg attacks
that's that skinny person jujitsu
sure all legs all legs
god there's a lot of great fighting
going on right now there's a lot of
great fighting going on and we're in the
sixth round brandon shop and you're
watching you're watching kayla plant
catch canelo in the facebook it's not
no he's catching him he's not winning
this fight i'm telling him i'm a kayla
plant fan i'm telling you right now dude
look at that body shot
he said i can't take this anymore [ __ ]
brian look at this though now now
whaling is doing exactly what her game
plan is yes
but and i was predicting rose submits
her from down here so we'll see now
she's getting up
she's saying down again we're gonna have
a long night and boring night yep there
you go hope back up there you go back up
break that damn back up back up back up
that's that clinch thing oh
with that [ __ ] her nose up
hitters i hit her oh yeah i didn't see
her elbow to the beak
beak oh and can all starting to take
over because it's almost six rounds
because that's right
that you're saying what is this stamina
oh yeah oh jesus christ he downloads the
data and then goes to work that's
amazing it's called the mexican shuffle
it's like aol up uh [ __ ] dial-up
it takes six rounds and then oh oh god
and killed
oh he's gonna finish
definitely not gonna finish him
no wow i'm not gonna i don't even really
know but brian you're pissing me off
i don't even know what's true but you're
still pissing me off chris listen i'm
just saying watch kale plant oh god dude
look at look at look at rose nominations
oh
hard left hook by canelo i gotta get
writing on my back like that oh that'd
be sick you should too and it should say
watch kayla playing it's so difficult oh
it's this is impossible i thought it's
gonna be easy it's a nightmare it's a
[ __ ] nightmare yeah my eyes hurt i
know oh i'm only watching wow yeah i'm
just going to pick one
someone keep me posted i'm watching the
boxing
[ __ ] how is canelo this good how the
[ __ ] are you this good people oh you're
oh you're swaying over now huh i'm just
saying man it's impossible you just keep
doing the pressure
pressure he can stand there and just
look at you dude i knew canelo was
fighting because when i was leaving the
house tonight my girl was making flautas
wow
look at this
[ __ ] about flautas and i know about
flowers oh yeah you know about pasole
huh but i don't know much about
patrolling
soup dude
they're making flauta but soles and
there's flaming hot cheetos all over
your goddamn house flaming hot cheetos
yup i know about those too i love them
don't wipe your eye if you're eating
dude don't take a [ __ ] within a week
don't i don't [ __ ] anyway but okay look
at rose b look at rose catching her
three times in a row like hey you know
what's embarrassing is i eat those foam
hot cheetos and you know how they get
red all over your pants and i like to
grab my dick when i watch tv and i have
red marks all over my sweats wow on my
dick parts don't do any of those things
hey man eating flaming hot cheetos
hello
i'll take caleb plant's wife over
[ __ ] nose and he's just a [ __ ]
night of fights
and i'm pissed off i'm gonna watch the
replays brian watch this what
boom no mister bubba
boom what about that one all right i get
i'll give you that one now watch this
i've seen a lot of caleb playing
because because you guys don't have
something oh man i'm sorry man like i'm
these replacements these tassels gotta
go yeah they do they're hot they're real
horse and i like this guy already you
know because i like his look he's very
tall he's very lean he's a tall drink of
water like myself you know what i mean
yeah but yeah you know those are castles
i agree terrible look madison square
garden really wants some hennessy for
some reason
at the mgm resort those low kicks
ooh
rose and [ __ ] whaley are swinging you
tell you i remember you said a long time
ago before rose's amy said she's one of
the best athletes you ever saw monster
man wow monster just picked up on stuff
or what do you mean by chris said that
or i said that you did i said that
christmas earlier way earlier said that
really early in like 2006
when she was like in kindergarten they
gave it 10 9 zang yeah with the take
down makes sense
this is where canelo takes over dude no
i don't know about i don't know i think
i think what happened here is caleb goes
i figured him out
i mean
a hell of a fight
uh oh caleb's got his hands up now
here
i mean this is well we were quiet for so
long it's so distracting it's so
distracting nobody can talk sure if you
if you guys are listening sorry hey you
see the scorecards being see the
scorecard i do yep
it's [ __ ] it's this we should never
do two fights at the same time i'm
watching the boxing and then i have an
earpiece in the other fight look at the
way he [ __ ] loads up look at the way
canelo a little girl you make one
mistake no don't jump on the canelo
train i'm just ryan slowly sways over to
the [ __ ] yeah get out of the guy
who's gonna win i'm not he's all the
score cards like you know what your nose
actually looking pretty good tonight six
no six runs in brian goes i guess i said
kills
that's what he starts doing i didn't no
i don't my voice gets real grounded
there is no problem here i am prepared
to die
i see oh i see the advertisement they
have so many oh trojans back now they
should make fun of fighters and uh
condom depot they'll have trojan on
there they were one of your sponsors
right bob no i mean fighters fighters
don't wear condoms condom deeper what a
[ __ ] crazy isn't that weird no you've
seen like who's [ __ ] that condoms
who's [ __ ] that much
man i hope both these fights don't go to
decision
i'm come on rose kicker in the face look
at him stand up
stand there right look at him standing
there
what is it about thug rose though she's
[ __ ] super she's watering she's in
and out like water smooth stuff
for something about her oh
she's sexy she has that like she fights
hard she's got the knockout power
that's not right there's that like
little throw off the gloves she's
feeling comfortable for you baby yeah
she's feeling it for you really going
with the leg chest he's a champion she's
a goddamn champion kick her in the head
again yes please kick her in the head
at least my eyes are hurting and then
it's going to make the main event go
willie's tough shouldn't be there quick
wait at least who do you think is
watching oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] what happened rose hurt
rose hurt yeah rose went backwards
yeah but then then when whalen's doing
those leg kicks oh headquarters jesus
head kick and then she's back up rose up
the people watching this fight companion
who what are they mostly watching ufc
110 yeah yeah okay got it
110 percent i mean well that's because
well we talk boxing because
boxing's this combat sport we have to
cover this we have to cover boxing
because canelo is the biggest
only big boxing like i won't [ __ ] around
with anything yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
john and i talk about it we're like
we're not covering [ __ ] and i really
only cover big mma too i don't know we
got five more rounds in this fight guys
no oh [ __ ] five total rounds no i'm
talking about five more rounds i'm
talking about the uh oh you're talking
about boxing yeah
wow i'm glad someone's playing i want
one of them to end so my eyes will
recover i know i feel like a chameleon
one's on that one but i'm good i'm
straight man oh
no we didn't bet uh rose no no we did we
bet uh canelo
and i'm saying plants can last dude this
is a [ __ ] great fight with uh rose
rose is she's an animal it seems like
rose is losing yeah oh she tried she
tried to hit the henry zooto inside trip
oh that's great he just missed it yeah
it's [ __ ] he's got the best inside
trip in the game by far hands down
inside oh she took her down yeah she
wouldn't go straight them out she's
gonna straighten them out and just
[ __ ] [ __ ]
the leather on out
put the [ __ ] leather on i was putting
the leather on planty not really
he's catching a lot of brown you've
glove and shoulder how many times do i
have to tell you that love and show
rounds
no see glove gloves glove don't worry
about it relax everybody know plant only
had nine fights
plant is greatness oh [ __ ] nice shot oh
[ __ ]
oh dandruff they're playing for keeps
rose is a fog dude rosie's rose a
[ __ ] thug thug that's her nickname
thug
that up buddy
thanks i'm so glad brendan you see that
with the captain obviously over here
canelo's up yeah but you said because
because the fix is in because the fix is
induced oh okay okay but let me tell you
something right right right right now
look at look at our boy caleb plant who
can just sit in the pocket and not take
punishment hey can you calm down i'm not
going to calm down jones come on
the [ __ ] down dude no it's just not
what's happening you know it's weird
yeah it is
look at all these [ __ ] you guys are
so [ __ ] on canelo's nuts no i'm not
you're not i'm looking at the [ __ ]
fight and you're like you are you're
saying a bunch of [ __ ] it's unbelievable
man you're not seeing anything look at
caleb just going i got you i got you but
he doesn't have him though that's
probably literally gasping for air
he's not getting he's not getting
minus four counts i wouldn't say this
yeah
right now if you better not spot a shot
on canelo body shot on canelo dog deep
duck deep
don't say it like that he hit his elbow
now you don't know what you're josh i
wish you understood fighting
[Laughter]
have you seen that meme where the guy
goes silence hoe
it's just silence though
dude where am i supposed to look for
real where am i supposed to look it's
tough i'm trying to do i can see both i
try to do both
i can see both i'm doing both i feel
sick i close my eyes i can see both
oh [ __ ] high kick
how the [ __ ] yeah okay i was just
ripping that [ __ ] kill body
just turn it up i don't know lee kim's
body hey chris you're hurt
and watch this stuff
i let him stay up how about
yeah yeah uh he just went to bed josh
you're half mexican right yep
so there you go so your [ __ ] bias is
so apparent oh
that's a good point unbelievable and i
look mexican but i'm not i know i'm
actually more native american than
oh you're one of those yeah yeah yeah
elizabeth where's your car
how damn american are you oh i'm so my
mom's eighty percent my grandfather's
hundred percent your mom is that true oh
wow native american so i i'm gonna get
my whole 23andme done but i would
imagine i'm probably somewhere around
30. are we talking about apache navajo
uh yucky indian yucca yucca okay
why use cca yeah no no no no no
tell me about your own nationality and
fight no no no no it's y-u-k-i by the
way yucky hey brian yeah it's not yayaka
it's not like your friend yeah [ __ ] it's
okay it's on the tip of your head man
you get [ __ ] all over your nose you get
fighter [ __ ] on your nose
yeah there's some brown [ __ ] on there
damn so you're you're just [ __ ] got a
little on your tongue too by the way
shut up
no but honestly if you're making out
with a fighter's ass yeah yeah but yeah
it's all good it's all good i'm i'm
kissing it like a mouth how do you how
do you walk out with that that jacket on
though how do you think he's that way
you walked in with that yellow sweater
yeah bro
you got that from a [ __ ]
you want to know where i got this it's
hilarious dude the last thing i've heard
the last thing i heard when they get
when i when i put this on yeah was will
you wear this please no i know again no
no yeah yeah yeah
little knowledge was like no i'm not
worried
[Laughter]
so take it off or chris lillax as brian
would say but you were like i'm going
two-tone is that what you did yeah
that's what i did when i woke up who
made that jacket was it expensive or did
you get a thrift shop
i don't really know how much anything is
all right chris it's not in good taste
to brag about having money no no i'm not
i'm just saying is is a carton of milk
forty five dollars okay chris you're
it's not good no no it's not this cool
to be a that out of touch
you're acting like a real aristocrat and
it's [ __ ] obnoxious dude
as a man of the people which i am don't
say that dude you're not a man of the
people man people and i'm [ __ ] and
you're not really drinking your wine
that you brought together
it might have been more off balance
because hold on a second there's two of
these going on
i thought you were talking about the
other i'm not so weird you're talking
about boxing josh brennan
say sorry to me
i don't believe that foreign he's he's
answering back every time he's one he
catches max i'm gonna work on my philly
shell that's all i'm doing look at that
look at the [ __ ] look at that
popsicle seeing things that aren't
disciplined caleb unbelievable birds are
in the ring birds are in the
ring saying things that aren't there no
that's not true
tomato monsters look at this look at
caleb plant answering back not taking
the damage look at this
crazy just got hit three times they
don't have better camera views for
boxing with the ufc
because they have a guy do it who's
outside right now so the ufc has the
cameras on the cage yes
that's a [ __ ] good point how would
they not figure that out because
like with bellator ufc we've gone
through ufc we've got like 17 [ __ ]
cameras grown all like on the cage these
guys like you have three boxes
you could get
hit with a big right hand right there
oh nice take down take down right there
get up rose
sure you dropped her oh she didn't get
her back no shaking [ __ ] that was too
good and at this point it's anybody's
game
chris goodbye i'm a commentator
[Laughter]
we got one second it's over it's good
she's good she's safe she says more wine
guys oh powerful mike tyson what are you
doing you're doing this whiskey now i
get centauri here i get buffalo treats
you know i'm a white i only do whiskey i
only do brown i only do brown i don't
know this one i want to do brush this
one's real good oh my whiskey
if it ain't brown ain't taking it back
this is that damn nice one
is it nice
oh yeah but i mean look at that
like the bubble tree's like in my house
for a dollar yeah yeah i just do buffalo
chase all night oh missed wow let's see
the left hook come back
come on never came back i'm telling you
he's missing really
swearing i don't think he's killed
playing did you wake up this morning and
i decided you would go to the justin
timberlake
outfit
i'm [ __ ] furious what's gotta be
confused is the second one the second
zipper what's second zipper fashion
nice all right fair enough fair enough
okay
okay i don't know honestly i've tried to
wear a beanie like that before and it
just slides off my head how does he send
you a picture of him
in the morning like someone where today
you're like ah
i'm a little suspect
i'm gonna start wearing a beanie i go to
a champion you should wear a beanie like
what goes on
don't don't stretch it out with your egg
yolk but don't be shitty okay
you know what you know me dude i'm a
really good friend here oh should i go
emo brandon oh no not again dude hold on
oh no
that's you right now
i miss her so much look at him
ocean avenue yeah yeah heartbreak
central that's you right now
oh 29 28 zang huh oh [ __ ] i have it the
other way around i have too many zippers
go ahead oh someone says 30 27 zang wow
what
jeez
what jedi
maybe i'm missing the fight maybe i'm
missing the fight i i got rose up i
could be honest i don't know what's
happening
with that hair it was
i don't know what's happening that rose
up two to one that's terrible you take
those let me shot it be honest oh hold
on a second guys give me boxing
instructions it's steve give me box
instructions right now come on rocky
yeah that's what you look like i do come
on you got the talent to be a great
friday they said you became a pup this
is what you are
wow
i called it it's what you are wow yeah
you don't want to know yeah i didn't
have a manager yeah i had no manager
rocky yeah you're the same team there's
spit coming out of my cheeks for
nails in his clubs you look sweet i
didn't have no manager wow i want to be
a manager i'm 75 years old no how much
do you look like a [ __ ] guy that like
is still in acting class in new york
city
brockovich the play or some [ __ ] yeah i
got the same part as the [ __ ] what's
his name it's a play our boy carol plant
is answering the [ __ ] back
take put your hat put put this hat back
did he not look better in it honestly
dude
honestly dude let me see okay i'll take
it dude you look like i missed what wear
it yeah you look like a captain of a
ship that can't find crap steve zizu
steve
jesus steve is easy dude caleb plant oh
oh god with one of the greatest of all
time
in some ways i don't think anybody beats
yeah
you're gonna win your money because i'll
win my money because he's looking great
oh
two nine minutes left though
guys guys it's 2 30 a.m
[Laughter]
dude i've got uh i'm i've been singing
it's only 9 30 where are you you've been
singing you've been working on your
voice yeah
yeah holy [ __ ] all right thanks for the
letter so what what were the scores it
was 3-0 right someone said three oh no
that guy's on the third
yeah these two ones i started a job
john mccarthy says is two one rows like
i just said two one rows well that's
what it is it's two one rows yeah big
john's speech i have a two one run
as do i as do i but but but i'm glad
you're keeping up there buddy don't be
surprised if caleb wins this fight okay
b i will bet you my entire life okay
your bet isn't whether he wins your bet
is that he goes distance he's definitely
holding this that's a good distance
oh that's cool bro everybody's ah
caleb's gonna lose in the eighth get the
[ __ ] out of here oh size
eats only pizza and stuff
he can't finish people then
significant strikes
now we got we got two more rounds for
kayla plant okay
and look at nero's not magenta rose rose
probably has this round for sure
so she's up recording a big john three
oh look at this look at that
if her boyfriend couldn't fight i'd be
knocking on her just not he's like yo
what's up girl
she her boyfriend could fight though oh
pat berry yeah i think that's her
husband that's right yeah
i trained with him for years he fell
down he go down pay me my money done pay
me
money count oh and yes you got the count
and it's it's the top of the 11th
yeah what the [ __ ] hey you're his coach
mate give him some tips uh
come on what happened oh [ __ ] he's done
he's done
no keep going i ain't going the distance
oh they're going to stop the fight and
then i get my money hold on hold on hold
on
oh my god wow
wow
oh cause you know what this is a late
finisher you didn't know that though
that's fine oh i won my money damn
anyways is it over [ __ ] it
he won
oh that's [ __ ] he's got the guy here
god is he good
god damn it he's so good
what weight class is he what is this
weight class it's boxing so we don't
care you know what [ __ ] dude but he's
going for the first time ever he's doing
something canelo
he might be the greatest of all time
bound for number one by far i mean i
mean
dude how about that [ __ ] raiders
receiver
stop
stunned henry stuck wait what gets drunk
was playing uh like top golf in vegas no
no topgolf in vegas gets drunk 104
i feel like i want to get to the end
yeah
did someone die he's like she's in a
chevy though so yeah hits the back end
of a girl's car she catches on fire they
can hear her screaming she burns alive
the dog another small detail
what kind of tires did he have
the dog is another charge what was the
weather like the dog is under the charge
but he was trying to pull the animals
corvette yeah
suv she got on fire he was hammered he
gets cut from the raiders probably going
to prison for i don't know 10 years
manslaughter yeah dude
they said are you supposed to play on
sunday they said two to three isn't that
crazy
yeah involuntary minutes your lifestyle
what you did to somebody because
what happened yeah
they're saying they're saying
what happened here it could be like some
hey can you turn this tv off before i
have a heart attack wait
i gotta
i've never driven over a hundred and
four
never ever ever see i know
big [ __ ]
i got cruz
hey brandon you gotta listen to the
story so one of my sponsors oh grove
technologies they do like contracts for
the government
they were they were at me and mike swick
bobby southworth back in the day and uh
john fish and we rented us all lambos
yeah so we all get lambos this is in
vegas in vegas oh yeah stay restless in
vegas we're out driving on what's the
215 out there by red rock that long
straight away we're all racing i kid you
not
i'm at 160 something 168 160 almost 170
on a lambo
170 down the [ __ ] thing kid you're
not kidding a [ __ ] gixxer take down
next to me
[ __ ] one hand flips me off and
[ __ ] a motorcycle on a motorcycle oh
my goodness
i'm doing 170. he pulls up next no no no
i was about to but it was me i was like
he pulls up next thing in the [ __ ]
jigsaw and
flips me off gixxer takes up gsxr oh
gotcha
rachel dude
wow
gonna win this fight guys yeah she's
winning now for sure yeah she's winning
take down all right turn that tv off jim
before i want to see what he does
i have no idea what's going on with rose
and uh well rose is winning here you go
here we go
here we go there's three to one right
now rose
i'd be i'm down a grand now
i won this fight
oh yeah uppercut ooh uppercut cut again
he goes ding ding ding all right shut it
off no that's what he did and then watch
this and then this yeah
and then he comes back out he stumbles
into the road that's where he's bad now
he goes ding ding ding remember killer
plane only has nine fights dude like
he's still going to be a monster yeah
right on the channel you're literally
dealing with the pound for pound
business you're dealing with best of all
hagler herns
listen let me ask you a question what is
i never knew this what does pound for
pound mean like no matter what the waste
weight class is yeah it's like khabib at
the time it's pound for pound and jon
jones might have been number two but jon
jones is 205 pounds could be fights at
155 gotcha look at rose now and qb's
weight class was um a lot harder to
become the champion yes oh really john
jones the guy
oh there's the fighters there's a guy
named mighty mouse who fought at 125.
i've seen him he's so dominant i've seen
they had him for pound number one that
guy gets hit in the face like it's
[ __ ] a fly just yeah yeah i mean
they're tiny it's like it's like our
kids fighting oh i got you
who is this who is this
mighty mouse oh he's yeah the cartoon
what happened that cartoon how is he
doing was he fighting
he's in uh one championship how's that
going come on uh he lost his last mma
fight he's fighting uh straight up he's
doing like a super fight where they do
kickboxing and then mma so one round
kickboxing one round mm-hmm wow
that's quite
making money i guess
sure
man rose had to earn her child tonight
yeah this wasn't a [ __ ] no
no no you think she won but this shows
you she's just a better fighter she is
she is like if she didn't knock her out
in the first round you know that's what
zhang said she goes i could accept if
she would have beat me for she beat her
she put her everywhere yeah yeah she
went to the ground and stand up dude
look at this rose rose dominating right
here yeah
almost like how i cannot dominate a kid
yeah he completely dominated shut up you
guys you [ __ ]
[ __ ] but you could still make bang
dude if if if colby beats us so now you
and i are even though you want four
grand you're up uh oh yeah no you double
down no you've got to double down
i'm still up by two
so i'm down two grand but we went four
grand on oh oh oh oh jesus was your head
better no she just punched her in the
face
uh zhang is uh
exhausted
i'm just hard after this he's exhausted
i'm [ __ ] tired are you guys tired
nope
yeah dude i'll just drink my clothes
i missed you guys last week i missed you
guys last week but hey finally meet you
josh you're a huge
elder hugging
that was a hell of a fight but rose won
so far so he's just won that title again
so far so good i'm about 1400 bucks
yeah uh i mean i missed out on the gate
well i didn't i didn't bet on the i'm
not bad with you guys you guys i lost
that's too rich for my blood i lost 12
million dollars i want to do this before
i piss on my [ __ ] i lost 12 minutes
i know i thought it would win
let me do this read so i can buy you
more [ __ ] coffee
gentlemen the holidays came early
because manscape the leading men's
hygiene brand has launched new products
all new ultra premium body wash a two in
one shampoo and conditioner what yeah
it's time to give yourself the gift of
beautiful skin boys hair hair balls this
is i love it dude i guarantee your
hygiene routine will never be the same
go to manscape.com
cfc for 20 off and free shipping all
right do that the two one shampoo is
fantastic do you have a new model uh yes
it's good dude they got they got the two
and one shampoo it's their first
favorite dude i haven't then that's good
and then they got the the crop preserver
the crop reviver they get the
anti-chafing ball deodorant for your big
balls yeah
stand them up
what do i do about my smelly face is
that what you do you can cover with you
tis the season to load up landscape
products so you get yourself your dad
your brother your weird stepdad and
friends the best gift of all with
manscape performance package 4.0 get 20
off and free shipping by going to
manscape.com cfc that's 20 off and free
shipping at manscape.com cfc clean up
your candy cane this year with manske
tired of your regular mill
run-of-the-mill podcast
you guys you guys tired of frowning all
the time no dude come on if you want to
turn that on i was in the middle of my
read oh i thought you were done oh i
want to get it hey dallas are you sick
of dressing like crystalia no
come on come on improv next thursday
friday saturday i'm gonna shoot my 30
minutes
christmas i'm not gonna drop yeah
chris rawdilia that's what we're doing
we're running with the christopher idea
thing are you tired listening to most
podcasts well here at congratulations we
kill it all right okay check it out
good good you guys want to see actual
artistry and not just stand up come to
off the hook comedy club if you like
fish and you like to do it
do you like fried shrimp and comedy if
you like to like fish and wiggles
you like to get really do you like to
giggle come on down fish
you like fish with tartar sauce and
giggles
into a guy so november 11th what go
ahead okay okay yeah sure let me just
ask you a question yeah sure i love fish
okay you know that yeah but i love
tartar sauce but also i'm sick of
frowning and i'm not busy in november is
there anything that i can do from
november 11th to the 14th no way there's
a place called off the comedy it doubles
as a seafood that's in tables
that's in naples it's in naples do they
have cocktail sauce yes and i'm there
i'm going to be on
is the lighting probably weird it's
weird as [ __ ] because i don't like is
this is the stage really small is the
stage really small the stage is not big
but i'll tell you this i'll tell you
this if you want to eat your [ __ ]
salmon or no or just scallops and you
want to they have tilapia [ __ ] yeah they
do whoa you want to [ __ ] laugh at my
[ __ ] comedic artistry yeah i'm there
from november 11th to the 14th oh come
on i'm free those days butterfly shrimp
and [ __ ] hey
hey b what if you like barbecue you want
to fart come to addison improv dallas
next thursday friday saturday that's it
brother
barbecue fart wow
here's the thing dude i i i love
barbecue and i hate frowning but also i
love when my anus is open
farting is there anything i can do i'm
free next party though i can
do you like dallas barbecue yeah like
the pecan lodge and stuff because i
would say we said at the same time yeah
i love it oh my god this i'm so great so
get full on brisket oh brisket and dude
and all their macaroni i love making
dude are there too many cameras around
yeah the audience can't sit and we got
to cut out some seats amazing this
thursday friday saturday dallas
oh come fart have fun dude i'll be
bothered you realize that we already got
well
my comedy's gonna be off
this is
josh is that
hey for rogan it's jamie hit it for chin
it's bring it up bring it up yeah bring
it up perfect you really want to make
google openings nah all right i'm good
at [ __ ]
terms dude hey you know what um
it's crazy that if we all fought i'd
come in third
third
third yeah change your fight you guys no
no no i'm not gonna have four of us no
take a fight i'm not including but
there's only four yeah
you know the chi chimney is concluded
chris i would fold you like a [ __ ]
dude this fight is for whites only oh
can i say it oh no
turn it off so racist
that's so racist chris
chris exposed himself he's a racist
he's one of those like castle culture
[ __ ]
you're you're lumped in bro and you're
laughing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
laughing on camera
cheese and sometimes i'm not here i'm
gonna come
can go more yeah
it's on your head
i have so many waters
now did we get that water from detroit
where's that from yeah this is there
purified water from excuse me
this one's
they look nothing like her oh adopted
definitely adopted i don't know i don't
know oh no mom mom kind of looks like
her
mom momma got a little bit like yeah
yeah yeah yeah mom
yeah dad doesn't look like that maybe
his boyfriend
her and bad baby been together for her
she's bad dude she's bad how about that
camera that's a good camera right well
is that high down good as [ __ ] what is
that a 5k it's our newest camera with i
guess it's way more frames really yeah
do we have those cameras
do we have those cameras we have really
good cameras what are they called reds
they call those reds not those what's
the nerd talk
what's the nerd talk is it a red it's
called red what cameras did i just buy
chin
the blue uh you bought fx threes your
flash threes asm as7 threes leather
chicken uh making it up dude you're
cheering back there oh that was all
right oh there you go we have those
cameras time we got those
that what they're using
we're shooting the special in some reds
though i know we got reds on them yeah
yeah i'm sure
i don't know i don't know either i don't
know they could be blue it doesn't
matter yeah i have no idea
look at those sponsors i love all those
sponsors
it looks like a nascar get all of them
next oh look at his brother jack jesus
this brother who's jack
oh brian hurt
brian like came in like kramer who's
jack
[Applause]
[ __ ] talk about a body brian come
through the bushes you guys talking
about muscles
hey dude yeah [ __ ] you be respectful man
no i know be respectful i get really mad
all right i'm gonna pee you do get
really mad you do really
oh my god look at him dude who's gonna
win monsters his brother that's his
brother yeah emotional side no home
earnest no bias who's going to win in
this fight yes
come on come on your bet i don't care
about your bet don't don't put that
aside
because you're going to lose that i'm
going covington
how
wow and why how am i
i i if i'm his coach yeah i'm saying
don't don't get in the slugfest kick him
in the legs mm-hmm kick him in the
[ __ ] legs calf relax
because he's got those thin legs yeah
yeah so stat do not get in a [ __ ]
boxing match with us one he will knock
you the [ __ ] out but he and all right
barely not going for i know but but but
kick him kick him in the legs
blast them and try to tire him out play
that cardio game okay
that that's
no wrestling but you can't avoid
slugging it out that's a problem
what do you think if you're a coach you
know you're if you're a news coach who's
coach if you're a covington's coach if
i'm calling you zombies
if i'm uh colby kevin's coach yeah you
guys both [ __ ] up saying that word by
the way remember you said it [ __ ] up
if i am colby's coach i'm telling him to
wrestle early right tyler or he wrestles
right look when you look at this this
this it's been proven over the years i
know nothing about you
and i'm gonna educate you real quick
please when you take a fighter like
kamara usman who's muscular who's
explosive yeah he's got good wrestling
who hits hard
take those guys and what you do is you
you make them expend a ton of energy
wrestling
yeah i have you grapple wrestle pressure
josh here's the x factor i've never seen
usman get tired that's what blows his
thing here's the thing
if colby wrestles him yeah usual out of
those exchanges will not have the same
type of pace when it comes to punching
now now kobe is one of those guys that
he fights like nate diaz and nicky is if
you doesn't matter how much he wrestles
his punches come out the same yeah
they'll always be slow labored no power
right that's how they are but
it doesn't mean that i can't like touch
you and your chain goes oh yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] what happened right the reason
why it happens because you're tired
you're tired from all the grappling you
just had to do like right before that
it's funny because when i watch the diaz
fight the last one like a month ago or
whatever uh i was and then i watched
robbie
yeah with her
yeah yeah yeah i they
they were much slower with who
the the the one uh don't say max
completely though no ortega
[Laughter]
[ __ ] up
and they were much slower
than
older guys yeah okay yeah yeah but nick
nick's this older he's 39. okay so it's
kobe is a nightmare
he is [ __ ] he is he's a buzzsaw
nightmare i think if he wrestles camaro
first in the first round
he's gonna he's not just wear him out
but he'll make his arms slower that all
that muscle doesn't come out as fast
after you've landed some shots here's my
question here's my question josh when
was the last time colby fought i'm
getting cheesed he fought
me a piece no he fought rob uh he fought
uh woodland beat the [ __ ] yeah eight
months ago though he looked good more
than that
but but remember camaro was like twice
kobe fought one so it's not like
overflowing
that's true that's true kobe fought
woodland yeah
where
2020 i believe
do they genuinely not like each other
yes yes they hate each other
bro if if someone tells me they're like
oh yeah your dad came out of prison i'm
gonna punch i'm gonna fight you [ __ ] i'm
gonna do you when you take it personal
it's weird right i'm gonna kill you it's
a little over a year ago i'm gonna kick
you in your [ __ ] what do you want
uh i like this a lot that one's nice
fight was crazy smooth good yeah goddamn
camaro can punch man he just got that
[ __ ] so he fought woodley september
of last year 20 20 20.
what a fight this was remember this
[ __ ]
damn what's this guy you cannot yeah
cannot cheese fight
me you look like you
i'm bro
i wear harvest bodies
you come on workout you work out every
day you do i do i do
i do
that's why i look the way i do that's
why you don't look the way six two six
two six two
dude wait nine six two six two
you pull the hype card on it yeah
five ten [ __ ] you up five tip yes six
twos just dude you're [ __ ] you
whatever
bro [ __ ] it smash that you're my new
best friend give that [ __ ] a black guy
but try to put a stick on it you and i
are the same song he's like no you're
taller right
you're kidding me good god you're right
he's taller don't look he just said
you're the same i know so we will pay
you oh we will don't don't don't like
play dumb
i'm not playing dumb how much do you
weigh chris
290.
chris he got president he got brian
balls brandon
so wants to be like spelt and kind
are you an xxl like real food
hold on don't eat this hey hold on hold
on hold on josh hold on hold on i don't
cut off shoulders oh jeez
if i wear a triple x you you know how
insulting
you're a double x though yeah you're not
an extra ripple excellent i don't shop
at bacon
crackers in your mouth
oh my gosh so nasty
hey is it weird i kind of root for kobe
because he's talked so much [ __ ] there's
so much pressure on him if he loses he
can get so much backlash yeah
is candace walking out with him
i think we root for him because we know
he has he's actually a good dude it's
just like a facade you hear when i do
this dick man it's a stick yeah yeah
if any of you guys ever met chill chill
it's just [ __ ] amazing he's awesome
he's [ __ ] such a nice guy great
cheryl's a great guy great guy
and have you ever been around him like
when it comes to fight stuff he's like
him or dominic cruz
i have never smart put it this way like
all right people should understand this
i have trained with john fitz for 15
years
cheryl sonnen was trying to tell when he
came to bellator trying to tell the
crowd
that john fitch was the babe ruth of mma
at the end of his conversation he had me
believing that john fitch was the babe
rutherford very smart john fitch though
never lost in the ufc he was just
a grinder but but like babe ruth
competition compete against black guys
huh like babe ruth think compete against
like cubans and black guys
[Laughter]
i'm going to take you down i'm going to
[ __ ] you up and i'm going to submit you
or i'm going to finish you whatever it
yeah is
about rolling with uh khabib i was like
what's it like to roll he goes
who said that who said that jonathan
john fisher talked to him yeah
in san jose really really came to my
show yeah
i heard khabib throws around like luke
rockhold and [ __ ]
i don't know i don't know about that
okay
he can take luke down wow luke can get
up
he has a really hard time he's getting
luke down yeah
luke luke has produced 220 pretty hard
time getting up yeah but wow that's the
thing but when it comes down to it if
there were a fight luke quinn's yeah
luke luke with the power of the series
but she's your size right
i mean abs of [ __ ] losers yeah luke
is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i've seen i've seen khabib fight
guys at 185
where's lucy at 185 right but the guys
are really too old world class
kickboxers fighting glory fighting all
these other like but they can't wrestle
but they can't wrestle oh my god what
are we talking about he the
they're working around whatever and the
guy started lighting up khabib he was
like all right fine but there was
they're really just working like
supposed to be working like yeah keep
using mad [ __ ] just double lasers now
i'm fine
whole whole team has to pull the break
of them yeah i'm like oh gosh
savage khabib uh facetime camaro and
said break this guy i know he's cool i
know i know i know he did hate him he
hates him because look he was one of
those guys he don't like [ __ ] talking
yeah he don't care who he doesn't care
who you are
what you do
like he loves everyone but when you
start talking [ __ ] about people's
families
hey how rich is khabib
that's what i well he's got to be really
rich okay he just stopped no no so he's
so he drives like a rav4 in dagestan
he's filthy rich yeah but he is from the
schools right no no no no
because
he's fighting no no so here's that yeah
but he's like
people think he's coming his money comes
from fighting his money came from friday
but like he's got
is putin give him money or no no not poo
poo i'm sorry
yeah i'm sorry dude don't no he's you
know he's got other people that are yeah
i know who's the head thank you
he hates gays no he's a chess chest
he's close where does he make his money
from not from fighting or from fighting
he makes him he made a ton of money
fighting this guy hates case but he
needs to he's funny money
like he kills him yeah he's back he's
terrible just being him yeah just
sponsors tough show enough places yeah i
get it well you have to remember how him
is that he like he he's one of those
guys like put it this way
he he called me up he was
i i didn't talk to him for a whole lot
because he was mad as [ __ ] i had conor
mcgregor on my show
really
mad about that he's like why why does he
understand business though connor's huge
not abyss to him oh yes
it's princess this is the principal you
are close with him i am so with i'm with
khabib now
wow
no
i didn't ask him first and that was the
problem the problem was is that i have a
partner in my in my show for weigh-in i
have pete john john yeah he's managed by
paradigm paradigm is massive i didn't
know that yeah yeah connor
so they're all together and i'm like so
i gotta put up i gotta put in a hard
spot but i'm like you know what i get it
it's gone
let me let me just let me i'll do it but
i'll keep it professional
you're not gonna jerk them off but yeah
i'm gonna forgive you eventually
we're working on it yeah it's it's it's
it's working ah it's all right it's just
so all these on my side islam is on my
side abu bakr is on my side is have you
had islam on your show
yes
so he's great really he's [ __ ]
amazing he's a superstar he can be great
he's fair he's got to learn to relax
like his [ __ ] talk is feels like his
force he's not like i feel like he's not
forced i feel like when he's like i'm
going to kill you yes
he will he will
was a stock i put all my money into him
he's so good i really work with plastic
bottles so good i know i know look at
this
oh it made a very he later he laid leg
i'm like no no i never say late night
i'm just saying buddy no hold on two
conversations
was hilarious can you tell me islam
as that good inside the practice
arena he's a good period no but i'm
saying so and he's dominating the ufc
yeah so i'm like man if he's better than
this yeah he is he's going to take over
the world is he is like when you watch
our show from like two weeks ago i said
when he won this fight what i said
he is he's in the mount rushmore of the
best fighters i've ever worked with
could be i've yes no no
islam
the top five guys have ever worked with
the top fighters ever trade with give me
give me your five so it's uh
kane kane
yeah mickey yeah kane
guns from the rocky mountains frank
shamrock's in there but he's like
because he's old school judy brown
so those three uh thomas when it comes
to civil rights
i've i put like i put i put kabir had dc
probably
i put islam
zombies here in that mix so five six
five six is those guys the best guys
i've ever worked with ever in my life
mount rushmore who else islam khabib did
he just said
no we just went
and then i would say like
anime
i mean 85
ufc champ no bg prime is better than
that i love rockford i love rockets i'm
going to hit you i'm going to get you i
want to punch you in your [ __ ] yeah but
i'm here ej is prime
you work with
he's mount rushmore all right cool he's
running for governor of hawaii bro
bro governor white yes go hawaiian he's
going to be
right yes governor
he's a good fighter bro these guys have
been there like when people talk about
like states being stolen in elections
that's the state like yeah like oh you
know like they've they're so corrupt
that's your native american side coming
out right now i don't know josh
agree with you you shut your hormones
hey well if you want to rant about us
giving back land [ __ ]
yeah
oh my god
oh yeah
yeah
how do you make all that money 40
million oh dude
he [ __ ] conor mcgregor yeah but that's
the biggest force deal in history for
mma for him for his whole team yeah
sorry for him for islam for alaka the
biggest sports deal ever ever in mma
sports history all right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're talking
about khabibo
yeah no no no the the other day what's
his name oh yeah
i believe yeah
yeah seems like a tough character i
believe oh look at this look at [ __ ]
theo who's ready for a fist fire
dude he lives out by big john yeah i'm
about to oh big john should go on this
i'll hit him big john should go on the
spot he should yeah oh he's dancing he's
where he's yet here we go here we go
here we go
perfect perfect because big john's in
knoxville are you moving
no no not thinking about it
i know i can't i know i know
but you guys move
chin chin was down yeah i jumped
the man dude you know i went and looked
at houses in uh austin and i called i
called chin and he's like i'm dead i
looked too i looked in austin but
christopher then i saw all that [ __ ]
that was going awesome i have to have a
house in uh look at this house in uh
dallas all right i love you i love
dallas i love dallas dude i love it i
love san antonio i'm looking down right
outside
for me i like dallas i like houston i
like uh san antonio is for me san
antonio for me housewives was amazing
chris can you not economy-wise
the whole place
that's a lot i thought you were gonna
move out by me dude i thought you would
come out here here we go here we go here
we go let's go
against the cage i got i got colby
yeah brandon i think kamara wins but i'm
kind of uh
i believe i believe that camaro's going
to win yeah this is a very risky battle
i'll tell you right now if corey
wrestles if colby wrestles early he wins
this fight at this point it's anybody he
wrestles early
of these guys what are these guys going
to come through this is groundbreaking
who has skinnier legs chris or kermarose
oh wow that's right that's a little bit
comfortable
we're the same size guys come on
very very very we're the same size yeah
we are we are on the same so i don't
have skinny
[ __ ] thick thick legs three c's i
mean i could barely hug one leg thanks
man yeah no problem that's weird is your
son half at legs no my son is a tall
drink of water but does he have skinny
only one all kids have fat legs oh no my
son's lean bro
oh
josh dude i looked at my girl today
should we put him out she was listening
to me
he'll grow i mean he'll grow out of it
maybe not he's your son
[Laughter]
oh
[Applause]
not good not good oh people don't get a
twist camaro can [ __ ] wrestle dude no
you can russell you use juco national
champ right yeah i think he was
roommates with jon jones i thought it
was naia masterchef but i think kobe has
the higher pedigree wow well he wrestled
at oregon yeah oregon state if i okay if
my memory serves me correctly right now
there you go okay
can i can i change my background
can i change my bed i want to take this
one
now colby no you can't do kobe's only
wearing underwear he was a three-time
division two all-american he competed at
uh division two oh he's a division two
national champion dude that's no pun
that's colby no camaro
didn't say where he wrestled yeah
nebraska that that's [ __ ] clear why
did they throw kicks like that that are
obviously not going to land it's called
a fielder
iowa william penn university for one
year was a nia national tournament
qualifier
then nebraska occurring that's going to
end quick there's going to be are you
talking about colby
no all right looks like
this is going to anger
hey then go bring up kobe for me
brian we got four grand on this that's a
lot of money
is that how much we have yeah dude
because i was double or nothing
but now um i'm down two grand so you
don't need two grand when we leave i
really want to get some devour frozen
food for some [ __ ]
dude
all-american he's a two-time pac-10
conference champion you signed for a
fourth degree assault stemming from an
incident okay had some problems
he's a fighter dude take it easy oh look
at that oh
wow you didn't think about camaro
wrestling did you [ __ ] no i didn't i
actually didn't me neither
oh
oh um wow i'm uh
good point brian
oh [ __ ] you heard it here first
now usman is going to usman is just he
just gets better better he's so loyal
though he's so loyal to his defense his
his hands
brings it right back to his face
what do you mean loyal to his leaves
himself out of position a lot kamara
goes back to fundamentals hands up yup
good footwork good thing kobe doesn't do
that
we'll see with this new gym
uh
what do you think about his tattoos
chris oh the white guy
yeah nothing you see
that's weird
i see color which one is the white i see
color
and i respect it wow yeah oh no you
don't see it no you don't see it at all
i'm colorblind yep that would be the
same
people talking about are racist
yeah i like these tattoos are all right
i mean they're at least in the right
places and [ __ ] you know you don't like
when it's on stomach or back no it's
fine it's just like you like the
wrestling tattoo which one he has a
wrestling tattoo you see the back though
the american flag with the wrestling on
it
a lot of wrestlers get that oh really
yep i don't like honestly i don't like
color really on attack i don't like to
color i don't i know brian doesn't see
color but yeah
i don't what color do you speak of
jesus
you guys are killing me i'm colorblind
as [ __ ]
um how about how about kobe's last fight
uh trump and trump jr in the crowd
really yeah and he pointed to him
who pointed to trump pointed to trump jr
stupid joke sorry i'm really sorry
hey how chaotic was it when two of the
fights were on both fights wrong oh so
much smiling at each other smiling at
you i didn't know there were two fights
are they friends these guys are they're
they're oh hey [ __ ] asian yeah so
kamarulisman's dad missed a lot of his
life and went to prison yeah and colby
used that against him during the press
conference there's thing you broke out
was your dad out of prison oh [ __ ]
low blow oh wow
i don't like that [ __ ] that's low no i
don't like it this is personal it's like
i hate that you don't need to that's
colby that's what he does don't you need
to do it though
you don't have to be that way yeah you
don't want to be whittier there's
wittier things to do yeah like go like
you like you'll go like this oh yeah
well your farts stink you could do that
i don't know if that's that weird yeah
but you could if you said it with like
eyes like fighters that piss me off sure
oh he got headbutt that's what it was it
was a headbutt look at that it just
turned cheeky cheeks if we both went to
costco and had to get the same amount of
stuff i'd come out first because you're
dumb oh yeah okay you can't find stuff
that's not bad that's not bad you know i
mean a lot of words but i didn't get
that shirt from the charlie brown store
a hundred percent all right yeah yeah i
mean you're getting better yeah that's
better better but on the right path yeah
you know like give him another one b
okay okay um hey hey dude it's already
good by the way this one thank you hey
you know i looked at two double hayes
[Laughter]
sometimes i just do i go hey hey yeah
and the guy's just waiting waiting
waiting and then you're going to go well
you're a horse wouldn't you understand
what that means right i think so that's
a good one because you draw me in right
right
you smack
oh man
chloe wrestle man colby wrestle kobe
kobe's going to lose his fight i think
he's learned when he tried to take him
down and camaro [ __ ] reverses he's
like [ __ ] he's not wrestling him so
that's the problem so there you bet
foreign nope all right you sure because
i don't know how it works oh no wow uh
they go all the way down to his he's
like a stingray yeah he's just
unbelievable he's built like a stingray
he's got it that's kind of like how i
have it strong are you stingray he's got
some he's got some thick i mean look at
how far down his lats and he weighs how
does he get down on 170. he puts on
deodorant like this
he's so big seriously he's so big bro
he's so what he's doing
shot evans yeah
when you see he's not big enough to
compete at 85. no
85. oh okay
josh
against us
this fight's so good
he's got to do the game but dude
there's been no weak link uh wrestling
wrestling
uh
i think so i think so too but i think
those two guys right there
out of there where he trains in sweden
which gusman's camp all those monsters
like oh you guys same with your boy
they're like dude you guys haven't seen
[ __ ] this dude doesn't lose rounds
hamza is a problem that's a problem dude
i don't know who the [ __ ] gonna beat
him i really don't hey josh look at me
he's a problem who is it who is it comes
at you my office
chin hit it hit it
oh can you please someone say that i
already knew how much what are you doing
i know i'm sorry
i feel like you're watching
so conor mcgregor was talking [ __ ] about
uh dagestan uh-huh this dude you told me
dublin
wait didn't he fight last time yeah and
destroyed that's right right right and
yeah i won money on that right right and
he was talking to the guy so that's the
guy who's a problem it's a nightmare
he's a nightmare look at that beard dude
yeah
yeah you want to fight that beard yeah
he doesn't know he has a chin he has
upside down head but
that's upside down the hair
needs to be on the top but it's all good
i mean legitimately
upside down
that that
head is upside down and it's all good
but it is right
here god
he goes oops oh [ __ ] i put the mouth on
the oh well just flip it around that's
what god did i put the mouth on the
forehead oh you know what [ __ ] it just
flip it around
here's the widow's peak
i don't like where kobe is right now
this is a weird stuff
no i don't like that jesus christ jesus
christ is right don't use the lord's
name and then i'm a soldier of christ
all right dude
you want to go to hell forever no i i
don't even want to go for a little bit
you know hold your finger in a match and
then that would be forever your whole
body okay i got a question for you chris
you're going to deal with it you i'm
sure you've dealt with it brian yeah my
son asked me today or when i picked him
from school yesterday
dad what what's god oh god i'm like yeah
yep you know what i do when my son asks
me that what son shut the [ __ ] up
that's what i do yeah my parenting is i
go hardcore
yeah
but your kid is small and he's yeah he's
impressionable right
i say shut the [ __ ] up and then i just
drive drive drive i drive far yep when
you make you still make them drink
coffee and go be like me yeah yeah yeah
yeah
bees my son loves coffee that kid drank
black coffee and sucked it down
how old
he's like one and a half well he looks
more than half but he's actually
you guys watching this fighter what the
[ __ ] i'm living it look at this camera
work by the way i gotta try go puff yeah
they do do it the best but put more
muscle on your back yeah it's
unbelievable jesus christ if he fell on
his back he would roll over without
using his arms oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh
oh [ __ ]
brian give me my [ __ ] money not yet
not yet not yet kobe well well god damn
he got drunk that's tough that's tough
that's done dude how [ __ ] good is
camara
uh don't get in a slugfest with him what
did i say
what the [ __ ] did i know it's right
he should have listened to you brian
i'm not sure he knows you exist but oh
boy oh [ __ ] that hurts huh
you know what the problem isn't tomorrow
when you wake up and you're oh really
really
wow like he's fine oh kamar's talking
[ __ ] oh really what'd he say i think he
said did you see the latest episode of
congratulations from chris lewis i don't
know if he said that it looked like he
said
i'm going yeah he goes if i lose that
i'll give a [ __ ] because i'm going to
naples
that's what he said he goes at least i
got tickets to [ __ ] off the hook and
it's probably almost all no i don't know
he said anything confusing chris's pod
isn't called you're welcome no come on
and then cody's like what and he goes
nothing that's a no that's a low blow
dude it's congratulations yeah well it
should be called you're welcome you're
on you're on patreon yeah it's called
weighing in by the way watch it
watch this chris
yeah patreon he got [ __ ] patreon.com
you guys caught twice
this is bad here damn right there yeah
gotta put him out yeah does he look a
bit like shane shane gillis no
crazy it's not a bad call a little bit
look at him
tonight
two knock downs that was not good i'll
give it 10 8.
that's a stunning round yeah
he looks a bit like shane gillis shane
if he's on keto yeah yeah yeah
here we go here we go colby's still
[ __ ] funny guys
josh
recommendation yeah the nazis and the
russians oh dude
guys guys guys guys i don't agree with
nazis josh josh uh and brennan when
you're kobe right now you're still
concussed what's going on here you
definitely rattled you're rattled
but also you're in the fight so you're
like [ __ ] it yeah
those kicks are
i don't
they're not going to connect right so
why does he even do them
yeah but it's the right it's round three
i think this one just shows
i think it
shows you he is a
nobody beats him until he decides to
quit
it's kind of like to feel like if you're
if you're reacting i don't like kobe's
kicks you just got caught though kids
like charlie brown
doesn't he
looks like he's not flexible enough to
do the high kick yeah who
uh the white guy
oh i do see who's which one's the white
guy
i don't know what the [ __ ] is
do you know what color means even um
i mean yeah i do yeah i do oh
it sounds like you what i know i know
what it means what what
color
like hey man
yeah oh god we're gonna go
right now
i mean sure that yeah but the mood would
be yeah i guess you'd be angry then if
you said it like that right hey josh i
feel like kobe's gonna be in a little
bit of position that chandler's in where
you're never gonna be champ
yep
you know but you can beat some of the
top guys but you're never gonna beat the
best look at camaro that's fair to say
the difference is that is that
tomorrow's our original retirement i
can't believe oh
apparently has really really messed up
knees who yeah kamara the black dude oh
he does yeah like super bad knees but he
doesn't show it
yeah i'll say and he's actually got thin
legs yeah yeah that was the joke yeah no
no i didn't know that's what you were
talking about until i said it that came
out i don't see his legs as being that
thin i mean he's got he's the smallest
ankles in the world yeah there's no
calves he's got thighs on them there's
no calves you surprise me the butter on
key is gaffman
that's what i'm saying i probably can't
get it but you know what when you kick
your calf you're opening up to getting
punched in the grill so
that's the problem yeah i don't say
grill though shut up dude yeah don't say
grill all right you got to say wet pink
i'm saying this fight is dope as this
fight is fire if you
i don't say that about guy's mouth
though chris we gotta leave gotta guard
your wet pink mouth if you're coming in
against us man he's trying to wrestle
that mouth looks like a cut peach do you
say that no but you could all right
is that guy eating a pomegranate is that
just the color of his lips yep uh-oh oh
i don't like that either it seems a
little racist no
i'm saying his mouth is all red no
you're saying it's purple you said you
don't see colors yeah punched in the
mouth
colored i don't see color you [ __ ] well
a little racist yeah you said charts
why is that racist yeah well i don't
know punch them out
i'm talking about no pomegranates are
purple
pomegranate
pomegranates are red can you open a
pomegranate no
dude hey brian i'm wrong
[Laughter]
you have to leave them
you're done
is there anything i can do
i just got to find a pomegranate [ __ ]
find a pomegranate or something hey
it's debatable everything is purple
that's [ __ ] red i'm just saying it's
fine it looks probably chris you know
it's red man i'm woke it looks purple to
me i don't i would never
chris you know what's red man please say
it's red
pomegranates
why you put pomegranate you got chicks
i know because she's on a pomegranate
diet you guys no no the swimsuit's
pomegranate
dude purple
colby is still slugging guys
man look at
usman's got those crisp beautiful shots
yeah straight piston he's got a piston
jab
oh those are purple as he gets brian no
that's a red that's alright look at the
fart right right
there's nothing you could do probably
dude
you know where you get pomegranates
the far right
you can pick them on far right i didn't
know that i didn't know that god dude
warming up dude oh [ __ ] wow he's
definitely going
but you know what he's doing he's he's
slow
oh i told you there's nothing
you can't hold it nope from the back oh
really told you hold on covington is as
good as it gets look what he's doing
that was a good round for goldberg are
they not friends they hate well they're
smiling for the seventh time so it's
like a sarcasm hey sarcastic seventh
time dude it's a star catcher but
they're smiling i don't i don't i can't
read through meaning like that wasn't
usman doesn't get tired yeah no he looks
pretty tired i'm tired
i don't know man he's
just a different kind of dude man a
different kind of athlete you know what
dude
it's like maybe i like you leave the
back here
what happened a little duck tail little
duck tailbone yeah a little bit got to
keep it duck tailed out
look man i i haven't had a little piece
in about a year dude i got to do that
i'll do it for you all right
third or fourth uh going to the fourth
check my phone
check my phone everybody jackson huh
what's that and everyone loves me wow
amazing dude my friends are watching
[ __ ] this right now fight fighter
fighter in the companion
i can't believe colby's come back man i
thought he was [ __ ] he's not he died
in that chopper oh
my god i'm sorry i didn't mean to what
it actually happened i didn't make it up
i feel bad that he did you know it sucks
oh there's powerful
but they really wanted to keep those
pubes down though all [ __ ] aside i
use my manscape all the time
on your head i really do use it
no i don't ghost you have pubes for you
i actually use it on my beard and my
pubes
i don't care god damn it dude that's so
caring i don't see why that's a big deal
i smell like you shave around your penis
and also shave it down whatever your
mouth let me finish my joke
no it's cool
but you know what i'm talking i got some
heat coming right so
when you stop in the middle yeah and you
just
right you're spewing from your [ __ ]
okay but i've got heat coming right yeah
now we don't get to hear it okay well
that sucks that sucks for us all because
i'm in for a really good time with
everybody and i'm just trying to add to
it i got you okay so i'm talking i'm
talking about this are you serving up
hot lasagna yeah i'm trying to okay
right i've got a huge deep dish
plate that just got out of the heat
right now exactly and it's got anywhere
and he's and i and i've got lasagna
so now what do you want me to do just be
quiet then it's just like
would you like to try some lasagna it's
for you okay you know what i mean but
everybody
what do you do dude
you [ __ ] all over my my lasagna and
that's that's not cool for everyone
right because now no one can have it
it's not fun right no one can eat it and
i wanted it you wanted it was it a deep
dish it was
yeah i'll tell you this though when you
talk when you talk high pitched like
that you're being condescending that
makes me super mad i'm not being
condescending no you don't do it with a
high pitch
okay that's not your regular voice
no it's not and you're being
condescending who's winning this fourth
round
well honestly it's anyone you've been
watching
you gotta take the belt away from the
champion brandon it's what i've always
doesn't make sense you gotta take the
belt away you gotta take the belt away
and right now you gotta beat the champ
to be the champion
wow these guys they're friends right you
know what they say in france what they
say about kobe in france
here
that's good
punch him in the [ __ ]
remember benson henderson would punch
you in the [ __ ]
thigh yeah oh just they're taking a
beating huh
josh did you fight benson
yeah yeah did he punch him in the thigh
no oh you found him in uh you punched me
in the dick you found him in bellator he
put you in the back i fought him in the
ufc he punched you in the dick yeah
joshua truck huh
yeah someone's got to be someone you
you know what he's right i haven't drank
any he's got to do it hey josh i'm
slowed down
this is [ __ ] he took a flight from
ireland drink more whiskey because i
wanna have to because you guys are so
funny i want you to read the [ __ ]
landscape pads
greatest [ __ ] ever keep drinking bro
i'll pay for your uber and you're
reading that you're reading the message
guys [ __ ] drunk [ __ ] i just
realized
wait wait wait i don't know i have fun
in the box
i think he forgets i flew from ireland i
know morning yeah but why do you sound
irish
i [ __ ] have got like i've got like
four hours like 76 hours i love you
you're safe here but you try i'm
is a great shut up back to this come
over here
get him more whiskey right now i want
him to landscape ted
josh you're reading that man you know
you're not leaving this room right now
you know
that much attention but kobe's kind of
making a comeback yeah for sure you've
been paying attention she's coming back
who's winning
look at kobe who does not get tired
colby's the better wrestler he's the
better wrestler josh but he hasn't
gotten a ticket he hasn't really got a
thing i couldn't understand that part
yeah it's okay
it's okay mama i love you so much you
keep drinking and and i want you drunk
and you are safe on this podcast and if
you ever you get drunk on every pocket i
will love you even more this is what
this is about it's about friends hanging
out who gives a [ __ ] if anybody judges
you [ __ ] anybody who judges josh right
now [ __ ] you
bro i'll tell you where people want to
be drunk and naples dude they're going
to be drunk and [ __ ] [ __ ] naples
will they get so they're next well why
why naples because i guess you think
they'll be drunk
does kobe covington make
mma and the ufc better or what hey hey
way too long
that was the way i tried you would do it
that's amazing
how did you how did it take so long to
say that
it was too long
that was too long i had to intercept
that that was too long
i i'm slow it's because all the cheese i
eat
guys i wake up every morning
you [ __ ] dude why pound it
your blood is gravy right here boom i
had a little bit of that cheese oh my
god oh my god oh
fight this is
game dude how about a not a mark on his
face not a mark on his face yeah osmond
that's cool oh
yeah if i'm a fighter i would do that a
lot of dude
different dudes different guys
josh thompson different guy you had your
wars
same guy same kind of guy brian you got
[ __ ] all over your nose again yeah
where's my makeup i had my makeup you're
trying to save yourself again
the way out of there where's my baby oh
yeah i'm afraid i'm afraid because
jessica
right now i love mr martin come on buddy
oh oh
dude [ __ ] we're in round five ladies
and gentlemen
good commentary
we're in round five later in round five
right now guys
look at this
dude just imagine we were the actual
announcers for you for this fight
people how mad would people be oh my god
so bad i love it they'd be like the only
guy who knows what he's talking about
no brady look at rogan rogan dead
serious
she's out yeah laughing at us right now
she's like oh my god i can't believe
it's a great fight oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
are you kidding me right now kobe
wrestleman kobe wrestle punch
oh
are you [ __ ] kidding me
oh my god that trailer oh
[ __ ]
wobbled colby covington
chris has a point he rocked him a bunch
of times that's when you're going for a
[ __ ] kill
we was sloppy because he's tired
i'm smart i'm getting smart i'm learning
i am learning
i am getting smarter each moment that
passes about the ufc
passes [ __ ] chris sent his cyborgs
watching
it's metachrist metachrist is back it's
met a raw christian watch out ooseman
covington is coming for that ass
[Laughter]
chris [ __ ] medical good yes that was
so good
metachris metachris is so smart met her
chris hello i am jesus chris chris
metachris
metacris who's winning this fight uh oh
he's wobbling
it's right now
anybody's game
[Laughter]
one of these two men will be the victor
don't worry josh at the end not that you
need my help but i'm going to help you
[ __ ] brian up no you don't need my help
you don't need it i'll jump right away
i'll evenly match to this dope because i
will [ __ ] i don't know i'm just
saying i will use my open hands honestly
after this all of you i'm going to go oh
oh oh oh he slipped don't have any slips
that was a slip guys relax it was just
an accident
it was an
accident
that wasn't a tko metachris
did chris said did chris send you and
now you are running out of battery or
what's going on no i'm just
tired
okay but i have had a long
i have had a long day okay so metachris
you don't sound human hello and you're
you're trying to
it seems like chris
said
chris senpai
i see
hello it's not working what did you eat
for breakfast nope he's [ __ ] shorting
out chris sent another [ __ ] cyborg i
didn't realize we were watching two
fights
not anymore chris does anyone have a usb
charger
[ __ ]
[ __ ] this is so embarrassing chris sent
in the [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] he said in that [ __ ] cyborg
chris i mean autocorrect i couldn't
really
understand what was happening when i uh
oh man chris auto correct great
oh [ __ ] tomorrow
yeah he did replenish as long as he
doesn't say anything racist
i am so into
powerheads
and cuervo
i'd love to buy crypto
dot com
there it is what no it's uh yeah
oh god damn it's god he's nasty
nasty he's gonna come out swinging it
with these this break here what could
this be though there's only 30 seconds
left i poke no that's as far as the
fight a draw i think
no
it's 3-1
oh yeah oh finger in the eyeballs
we don't like fingers in the eyeballs
here in the ufc dude it's definitely
frowned upon god damn that was an
eyebrow do you think he meant to do it
right now
no natural reaction yeah yeah
bad asses
hell yeah you just don't get tougher or
better than these two both of these guys
are nuts they do not get tougher or
better they're so evenly massive they're
so evenly matched you gotta
you gotta be crazy it's like shadow
boxing in a mirror you know honestly
honestly over the years i never thought
i would actually like agree with [ __ ]
with calendar oh
would they be your father oh yeah i got
deep announcements no you don't i
you and i were both wrong about him
wrestling no slug it out because he's
right there yeah he's gonna wrestle but
he has wrestled more to josh's point
he's wrestled more than he did last
fight yeah he's true but he's also
winning on the field three more seconds
yeah they're gonna let him there so
winning right
really
these judges who [ __ ] knows it could
be a draw
i hope it's a draw me too i love drawing
it was a fake punch you didn't i don't i
don't know who's winning this it's
through i got to give it to the champion
just because i want to say a 3-1 ooze
man
[Music]
well there's six seconds left i don't
think it happened maybe three two oh
you almost crumpled them
that's a that's a
term
wow look at that look at that let's kiss
let's kiss kiss me kiss me
are they talking smack are they cool
oh he's being cool oh have you seen the
latest episode of congratulations justin
there we go
i like that he's like you know where
that's not called you're welcome he's
like dude it's [ __ ] weird
so you check out the companion i hope
the town good stuff it was a good fight
that was a good [ __ ] fight yeah you
got to give it up that's respect you
know what you're right
oh you didn't mean it actually
sorry that's respect yeah i like that
right i i don't watch close enough to
judge the fight i would assume it's
three you gotta give it to us
you know what a great job tonight a
fight
you're a really good commentator i will
tell you i will i will give you that
they're not it's not gonna be a draw
no not with these judges what was the
last time there was a draw in usa
march
no there's been there's been charles
recently
he said march
it was one of the months
yeah
i think
jesus christ they are both that's
incredible man
hurricanes oh jesus you know what
i gotta give it up that won it that won
it guys that might have won it actually
i wanted that one and there it is and
there it is that could have been 10 all
right so now now watch this
god damn it
there have also been three draws in the
ufc yeah so three draws total that's it
that's it
wow that's not good
uh one was robbie lawler um
i think one was robbie lawler uh with
donald cerrone right
i don't know yeah
that's one of them
i feel like there's been more than three
evenly matched [ __ ] oh they're such a
good matchup oh my god they're such a
good matchup jesus christ that was a
great fight it was a great fight
calvillo rodriguez rua paul craig
that's one crazy judge i have that but
no way who's giving me that
49.45 woodley thompson was straight
drawn in 2016. i'll give him that
got that guy's body huh okay bodied up
huh like believable i love you liking it
i love it man i want to cuddle him just
see what it's like whoa whoo dude
anybody with a body like that
who me
look at these two look at these two bad
[ __ ] what a fight honestly i'll
cuddle anyone what a fight what a
championship fight
are you kidding me
hell yeah brian give it to him dude
i mean read them off and bruce's jacket
when you have this christmas jacket
that's fair very fair 77
seventy seven eight yep who's been won
one what's the rest of the [ __ ] score
yeah
that's a good question
we said that they'd go to distance so i
i win right what else no i won that dude
sorry buddy you'll be two grand so 48 47
49 46.
and what else the 4847 seems fair
well either anyway uh either way there's
been one who's been one what alpha what
a rare taylor being
uh rolly
he doesn't even look tired bro i'll tell
you he doesn't care about watches rogan
but he has nice watches yeah that's a
nice watch that might be a grand seiko
oh really
you guys don't know watches it looks
like
rogan if you ask roger how much does
that cost he goes i have no idea
i didn't know i didn't know how much a
carton of milk was so we got all right
man i thought it was 40 40 45 450 right
15 grams grand seikos are nice they're
expensive too for you the right one
great grass great craftsmanship
you want tag lawyer
probably what 200
tags are expensive they're like crazy
they're not like rolex no they're like
three four or five bra it would go rolex
and i mean brettlings are expensive i
love brown aps are ridiculous
is that who's that guy right there the
uh the dude this is
look at this
have you seen the latest episode of
congratulations that's what that's what
he's saying i don't know if that's true
really i heard his life
no his wife is a dime piece you can't be
world champion i have a dog look how
lost the guy in the back is with the
[ __ ] thing around his neck
[ __ ] lost his [ __ ] uncle faster
literally thinks he's at his house he's
see security come on bro shut up man
come on chris don't that's so rude to
say shut up but
hey what the [ __ ] is this now you're all
like tight with me
that's it all right kids hey i'm in
dallas this week thursday friday
saturday uh show's almost sold out
dallas asking improv shooting 30 minutes
special come on come on out the whole
crew is there everett washington one
night only november 27th that is damn
near sold out which i don't know where
ever washington's at but it's one night
in a haunted theater in everett
washington and then for new year's i'm
in how do you say that danny of florida
florida it's florida all right florida
oh yeah you know new year's eve december
3rd through 1st but this week dallas yup
brian you're at the heart doing hot
puppies i know i'm i'm at off the hook
comedy club and uh after shows i'll
probably come out take pictures it's uh
20 bucks to touch me and i know i know
but you get to touch me i mean that's a
deal but that's your hands still i know
it is where the hand's handled
palm face no palm face palm face really
really should we do a tsa thing that's
right okay and you guys can check me for
all kinds of weaponry and believe me i
got it but it's all comedic you know
what i'm saying guys i think november
11th 12th 13th and the 14th even a
sunday dude first time you're doing
sunday what about you but you're a
christian i know and i'm doing the
sunday all money goes to christ oh
really that sounds like a lie but i uh
off the coast okay and then oh by the
way
i got orlando florida improv november
19th orlando's fun [ __ ] yeah kansas city
missouri improv december 17th tonight
cool you're playing the three worst
places in a row orlando kansas city and
oklahoma i mean it's great it's cool
it's from bricktown comedy club that's
for [ __ ] new year's are you out of
your [ __ ] mind oh dude you're gonna
oh you're gonna bring in the new year in
oklahoma city yeah i'll come you're
gonna open for me
are you gonna cancel the show no no i
don't okay okay
request
just final answer you get it canceled or
not it's supposed to be good
it is a good room it's gonna be a good
round
chris it was a pelican though so it
didn't do that much damage
awesome all right kids we love you guys
you want real real in-depth analysis of
this fight go on over to
patreon.com chris dalia real in-depth
analysis of this fight go over to
rockfin for conspiracy social club why
don't i talk about that no [ __ ]
spiritual me and sam tripoli god damn it
no you don't talk about everything
rockford i'm out of business
you about business
right no idea
you're mad at business [ __ ] so listen
josh thompson big john guys we love you
dallas see you this week
you